Optimal at this altitude.
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I know what else you were posting
a question. No, it does seem like
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living tissue over
this episode is brought
to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is the global creative platform
that makes it easy for designers and
clients to work together from
logos to Apps, business cards,
packaging to books.
You name it.
99 designs is the Goto design
resource for any budget.
Right now my listeners,
that's you guys can get $50 off a logo
and brand identity package from 99
designs plus a free upgrade that lets
you promote your project on the platform,
which is an additional $99 value by
checking out 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim 50 that's t I m five zero so nine
nine designs.com forward slash Tim 50 as
many of you know, I've used 99
designs for many, many years now.
I've used them for book covers including
mock ups for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number one New
York Times bestseller illustrations for
the multivolume,
the Tao of Seneca.
It's an ebook series basically and other
graphic design projects and I've been
very impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you can
check out all sorts of stuff like the Tao
of Seneca to get an idea. Uh, they're,
they're really mindboggling.
Most recently I used 99 designs to update
the illustrations and the layout of my
five morning rituals ebook.
This is a pdf that I offer as an
incentive to get people to sign up for my
newsletter.
The illustrations inside are gorgeous and
I loved working with a designer who we
ended up selecting for the project.
You can take a look at that.
This is a real world example of
the type of thing that I use.
99 designs for@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim 50 99 designs designers
search tool connects you directly with
one designer based on design category or
industry specialization style,
skill level availability. And more,
you just check off the boxes that you
need to satisfy the criteria you want and
it will bring up the best matches,
or you can start a contest.
You invite the entire community to take
a shot at your project and then you pick
your favorite.
So to get $50 off your first logo
and brand identity package as well as
additional promotion on the
platform with the free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim 50 that's 99 designs.com forward
slash Tim 50 and click on the link
on the landing page, check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash Tim 50
this episode is brought to you by
Charlotte's web, which makes a CBD oil,
a hemp extract that has become
one of my goto tools. No,
I have never really talked about CBD oil
and cannabis has never really been the
plant for me and, and we're talking
about hemp, but nonetheless,
after several nights of inexplicably
insomnia, this is about a year ago,
I just could not get to sleep, saved
my life and after other fixes failed.
So Melatonin,
California poppy extract,
Dah Dah in elite athlete introduced me
to this non psychoactive extract and Bam,
problem solved. I had some of the
best sleep that I'd had in months.
Now I don't use sleep
aids on a daily basis,
but this has become part of my toolkit
and I hope to be exploring other
applications soon.
CBD oil products have exploded in
popularity in the health and wellness and
fitness worlds.
And Charlotte's web is one of the top
players that offers a broad spectrum hemp
extract with CBD in the form of oils,
capsules and topical products.
Charlotte's web products will not get
you high so that maybe that is good news,
may bad news to you,
but it does have some powerful benefits
and applications and it works with your
body's existing endocannabinoid system.
Endo meaning from within like endo
versus Exoskeleton for instance.
So endocannabinoid system
works with your body.
Some of the most common uses are for
relief from everyday stressors help in
supporting restful sleep, which is
what I most often use it for. Uh,
to bring about a sense of calm and focus.
A lot of my friends use it for that.
CBD is also known or becoming known
for helping athletes to recover from
exercise induced inflammation.
Charlotte's web hemp extract has
naturally occurring terpenes,
flavonoids and other
valuable hemp compounds.
It works synergistically to
heighten positive effects,
sometimes referred to
as the entourage effect,
which you guys can look up making it
more complete than a single compound CBD
alternatives or at least
that is what I've been told.
I do not know much about CBD alternatives
nor single compound in any case.
Check it out.
This stuff has really worked for me to
jump over to CW hemp.com forward slash
Tim CW is in Charlotte's web,
CW hemp dotcom forward slash Tim to take
a quick quiz which will determine the
best product for your particular
aims, lifestyle, et Cetera,
and they shipped to all 50 states.
Charlotte's web are offering listeners
of this podcast 10% off of their
purchase.
While there are some exclusions.
I personally use the extra strength CBD
oils or the extra strength capsules and
a,
you can see what might be a fit for you
on that page and there is a 30 day risk
free guarantee,
so why not try it out just to get 10%
off of your purchase@cwhemp.com forward
slash Tim and disclaimer,
these statements have not been evaluated
by the food and Drug Administration.
This product is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any disease.
Enjoy.
Yeah.
Well,
hello you sexy little minx.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to interview and
deconstruct world class performers.
Whether they come from the worlds
of chess, sports, business,
it really doesn't matter. We're
trying to spot patterns of excellence.
What are the habits, the
routines, the favorite books,
the morning exercises,
whatever it might be that you can
test and apply in your own lives.
And my guest today is a friend
we've been trying to make.
The podcast happened for quite a
few years now and he is a polymath.
You need to listen to this episode.
Nick Kokona says his name,
last name is spelledK , o. K. O, Nas.
Nick OCONUS on Instagram at n Kokona
us on Twitter at Nick Kokonas.
Nick is the CO owner and cofounder
of the Alinea Group of restaurants,
which includes a linea next, the aviary
Royster. I think I'm getting that right,
and the Aviary, New York
City and YC. That is,
he's also the founder and
CEO of [inaudible] Inc a
reservations and CRM system
for restaurants with more than two and a
half million diners and clients in more
than 20 countries. Now you might be
thinking, wait a second. Restaurants food,
that's not my thing. Doesn't matter.
We're going to get into philosophy.
We're going to get into
derivatives trading.
We're going to get into books like fooled
by randomness, the problems philosophy.
Hi.
Let's see peregrinations of an epicurean
and how nick seems to break every
industry or type of business he goes into
and the most productive way possible.
It's a really fun conversation.
But back to the bio Alinea, a, l,
I, N, e, a, which by the way,
I based basically an entire
section of the four hour chef on,
which was one of my books
because I was so impressed.
Alinea has been named the best restaurant
in America and best restaurant in the
world by organizations and lists as
diverse as the James Beard Foundation.
They give James Beard awards out,
which kind of like the Oscars in the
food world, world's 50 best TripAdvisor,
Yelp,
gourmet magazine and elite traveler.
His restaurants have won nearly every
accolade afford them despite the fact that
uh,
he does not or didn't at least have any
experience whatsoever in restaurants.
And he had some amazing,
amazing partners we get into.
But that set of beginner's eyes is really,
really crucial.
And we dig into how he cultivates
that a lot. Nick has been a,
he uses this word, a subversive
entrepreneur, which I agree with.
And Angel investors since 1996 he
spent a decade is a very successful
derivatives trader,
has co written three books and believes
in radical transparency and markets and
business. His latest effort
is the aviary cocktail book,
which is perhaps the most gorgeous book
I've ever seen. I got an early copy.
It is stunning.
It is just unbelievable what they've done.
It is self published,
has already sold that is presold nearly
a million dollars in copies and is being
released right now shipped right
now in October of 2018 it is truly,
I think the most beautiful book I have
ever seen and held in my hands so you can
find out all about it.
You can see all sorts of photos
and samples at the Aviary,
book.com that's Dubdubdub dot the Aviary,
book.com a v. I. E. A. R. Y.
Check it out so I'll leave it at that.
Please listen to this episode even
if you have no interest in food,
it doesn't matter. We span so many
different businesses, industries,
life lessons.
I had a blast with this and I hope
you do as well here to Nick Kokonas.
Nick, welcome to the show. Thanks Tim.
Awesome to be here finally. Yeah, yeah,
we have the benefit of having spent some
time together and I've been fed a lot
of caffeine by you and you're also a
great help with the four hour chef.
So I wanted it to right off the bat.
Thank you for that.
It was a really lovely experience.
It was kind of a fun thing
cause I remember when you
sent me like a preview of
the book and then you called
me to say like, Hey, you know,
do you want to say anything about it?
And I was like on a
chairlift and I was like,
by the time I get off this chair lift,
I will have a blurb for you
with such pressure. We, well,
which, which meant a lot.
And pressure I think is
the word to describe,
uh,
so much about you and your life.
I want to say trajectory, but I'm
not even sure that is the right word.
And I thought a fun way to kick off
the conversation would be to share with
people listening,
some of the back and forth that we had
when we were brainstorming what a podcast
might look like.
Because certainly I,
I don't think of you first and
foremost as a food guy per se.
And we were,
we were having this exchange
via text and then via email.
And I thought I'd just read one of your
responses as we were swapping different
ideas and uh, I, I, I'll probably
edit for space a little bit here,
but not by much.
And here we go.
I'm a huge believer in radical
transparency in business.
I give numbers and burn bridges with big
companies because I think that a lot of
times people don't ask the basic
questions and publishing, for instance,
how much did that book cost to
print? How many did it sell? Oddly,
those numbers are very hard to come by.
I dug for months,
years ago to do the Alinea
book the right way for bars.
Why does a bartender wash
dishes and talk to customers?
We've redesigned the bar experience in
one best bar in the world for restaurants.
Why is it the only form of entertainment
that has only mutual promise to show up
and then it goes into behavioral
economics and in parentheses,
I don't even know how to pronounce his
last name correctly, Richard Thaler,
or is it Taylor?
Taylor is a friend and investor
just won the Nobel prize investing,
been beating the market
for nearly 30 years.
Everything in all caps is about asymmetric
risk taking in information and yet
people,
people's perception of risk or
of what I do is that it's risky.
It is not.
And a in a separate exchange,
when we were talking about many of the
topics that you could talk about outside
of say restaurants,
bars and so on,
even though that's been a big part
of your life in reason, history,
many of these different experiments,
explorations, portions of your career,
topics that you could talk about
and then going into what you said,
they come down to a single thought,
really wherever there is opaque
information that should be obvious,
run to that gap.
So I struggle with where
to even begin with the 20,
the 20 options that we have here.
But maybe you, maybe you could,
maybe you could explain to
me how behavioral economics
and Richard Thaler fit
into this. Uh, just just
for curiosity's sake.
Yeah. I mean, well,
I'll go back to the word you used
options because I started out, um,
back in 1992 or three studying options,
trading derivatives trading.
And I think there's a huge misconception
about what that is because of movies,
because of the big short, because of,
you know, Wall Street, all of that. Um,
it's a bit like playing a game of chess
for a living or being the house at a
casino, that sort of thing.
It's about taking, you know,
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
decision per day and pretending it's like
a big decision tree. And any given
decision is, is probably got, you know,
if you're really good, 48% chance
of being wrong. So you have to be,
you have to be really,
really good at constantly
being comfortable being wrong.
But knowing that your overall number of,
of decisions that you're going
to be right more than Iran.
And so like I know there's
like a big theme, a lot of
the folks that you have on,
like they talked about success or
failure or how to measure those things.
And I kind of don't look at it as
a success or failure with anything.
I look at it as just like
is my pattern of decisions.
Correct.
Um,
and then getting back to your actual
question with Professor Thaler and
behavioral economics, and I mean
essentially what they're looking at is,
is decision making, what drives
people to make certain decisions?
What's rational about those decisions?
What is mostly irrational or emotional
or what decisions do we make that people
don't even realize they're making a
decision, which is often the case as well.
And then if you think about it, every
single form of what we do, art, commerce,
science, you know, I'm picking
a mate, like all those things,
um,
it comes down to a whole
bunch of decisions that you
make without often really
thinking about the decision itself.
Um,
not that you can go around
walking around going, wow,
I've just made another decision, but when
you are doing, you know, business or,
or starting a company or publishing
a book or whatever it may be,
you can be intentional about that and
realize that it's going to be an iterative
process.
And so I think that's,
that's been not only the case for me in
learning how to filter things through
that mindset. But you like when you
said there isn't really a trajectory,
like I kind of look at everything
I've done is, is the same in a way,
even though other people
look at it and go like, wow,
you went from being a derivatives
trader to owning restaurants.
Like that's weird. And I
studied philosophy in college,
so like people are like,
how do you go from philosophy to finance,
you know?
And to me it was all the same thing.
How was that that particular transition
or rather a progression I suppose from
philosophy to finance is one that you and
I haven't really talked about and that
that one is interesting too.
I'd love to explore for a second and
we're going to go into a million different
nooks and crannies.
Was Do you feel like philosophy was
studying philosophy undergrad was an asset
that then leader helped you or was it
just an interest you explored on route to
other things?
No, I, I can't remotely imagine
having not not done that.
And the way that actually I
did it was really interesting.
I had no intention of when I got to
college I thought I'd study political
science, economics, pre law kind of
thing, something like that. And um,
my very like second week
at Colgate University,
a wonderful professor who just passed
away last year at 94 years old,
really great mentor to me,
Professor Jerome Bel Myth,
I was a tenured professor at Colgate for
almost 60 years. Pulled me aside, um,
introduction to logic one o one,
and basically said, what do you,
what are you studying here? And
uh, I told him and he said, nope,
you're going to be a philosophy major.
I'm going to tell you,
I'm going to teach you how to think. Um,
and, and he would, he was the kind of guy,
like, there's like, there's
this great scene in a river
runs through it where the,
where the dad, you know, every time the
kid writes an essay, like the young,
uh,
you know,
fishermen kid writes an essay and he
brings it to his father to be graded.
He gives it back to him and
says half as long again.
And that's like long before
that movie ever came out, um,
professor Balmouth would,
would essentially assigned a paper to
the class and say it should be about 15
pages. And people would be like, well, how
long? And he'd always say like, you know,
how long has the piece of string?
Like it's however long it needs to be.
And then he would tell me years can't
be longer than three pages. And,
and people would be
like jealous. Like, wow,
you only have to write three pages if
you take it seriously. That is a much,
much harder thing to do.
So he really trained me as well as a
number of other professors there to be
clear and thinking succinct to,
to you know,
understand what logic was to process
information and really to look for
parallels in different fields and
different fields of thought. Um,
and so man,
like when I got out of school,
I went to law school for like a day
and a half. I don't need to pay.
I got into Penn like a joint JD PhD
program at Penn and as soon as I kind of
knew who the other folks
were and what their,
their desires and trajectories
where I was like, oh,
this isn't actually a
good fit for me. And, um,
I remember my future father in law told
my now wife then girlfriend that I was
in danger of becoming an
intellectual bum because I,
I dropped out of a dropped out of law
school before I really entered law school.
And, um, you know, I floundered around
for a little while. Um, but you know,
if you grew up in Chicago,
you end up meeting people who,
who had this unusual lifestyle. And that
was back in the days pre, pre Internet,
pre,
pre electronic trading.
I'm pretty high frequency trading where
there was literally people on a giant
trading floor that shouting at each other
and you either were attracted to the,
I don't know, almost
animalistic nature of that. Um,
and for me it was like a huge challenge
because there are people down there that
were, had phd's from Mit and then there
was people who were like, you know,
butchers that went down there with
$100,000 and just kicked ass. And, and,
and so it was,
it wasn't about your level of education
or any of the stuff I already talked
about.
It was about can you show up every day
and every day is game day and be really
disciplined and very clear,
headed in with chaos around you and
you get introduced to that world.
You know, if you grow
up in Chicago, you know,
some of these guys and some of them
are flashy and I can remember the exact
moment, and I'm not going to name a name
here as you'll find out why in a second.
But I was walking down the
street. I, I was like, you know,
six months out of college, kind of
didn't know what I was going to do.
And I was walking down the street and
I bumped into Guy I knew in high school
and you know, he wasn't the best
student. He didn't try the hardest.
And I was like, Hey, what are you
doing now? And, and he was like, well,
I'm just rehabbing these homes.
I thought literally like, oh,
he's a construction worker.
And I was like, you know,
what are you doing with him?
And he's like, well, I just bought
this block. I'm turning this all over.
This is a true story, but
this is so not like, you know,
a good reason to do something. But,
but I looked at him and I was like,
what are you talking about? And
he's like, yeah, I skipped college.
And I started out as a runner on the
floor of the merch. And now I, you know,
I own like 25 condos and
three town homes and I trade.
And I kind of went like, wow, you know,
I don't know what I knew
a little bit about it.
I'd been down on the floor before it
just visiting, but I was kind of like,
that's fascinating life. That is
truly fascinating thing. And you know,
I, I went down, visited the floor,
I had to fake my resume in the wrong
direction to get a job. That's true story.
Um, like people lie on
their resume all the time.
I'm probably the only person that got rid
of like, you know, my degree in my, my,
uh, academic awards and
all that because you know,
to get a clerk job on the floor,
the last thing they wanted was someone
with a good degree, Phi Beta Kappa,
magna cum laude, all that
stuff. Um, so I faked my resume,
got a $5 an hour job
and look for a mentor.
And I found a guy named Frank Serino who,
um,
was it Chicago research and trading,
who's,
which also was founded by a philosophy
major. It's actually very common. And,
um, why is that common? I
don't wish I knew the answer.
I don't know the answer.
I do know that there's three or four of
the largest trading firms in the world,
uh, run by philosophy majors. Um,
and if you look back at my,
my class just of of, you know,
there's a few professors in there,
but there are people who make movies.
There's a guy who runs an ad agency,
a large ad agency like it was,
it's a really interesting path.
It's not dislike studying physics,
you know,
like I know some great physicists who,
who are great in whatever they do.
And I think it's, I think it's a
similar discipline of abstract thought.
Like I can't think of anything
worse than studying business.
It just seems like a terrible
thing to study to me.
Is that because it's like the surface
of the waves in the ocean topically,
it's just so
nontransferable in a sense.
And then as you go lower and lower to the,
it's going to slower moving layers.
That's just more multidisciplinary
in terms of studying,
like the basics of how things work or
how people think. Yeah, I think it's,
it's almost like it's how to do
something or how to manage something,
but not why to do it.
Right. And, and so if,
if you're taught in 1992,
if I went and got an Mba,
I would have been taught a certain kind
of management that six years later with
the Internet would have gotten
blown up. And so for me, it's like,
I always ask the why question,
you know, um, when were, you know,
you were mentioning like the book
publishing or, or a bar, like, you know,
I just looked at some things
and just go like, why is that?
Why is it work that way?
Um,
and oftentimes the people most entrenched
in the system have no idea why they
like the third or fourth generation
of person within that system.
And they have no idea why a school
bell rings in the morning, for example,
or why a bartender is washing the dishes.
Um,
and often I don't know the real answer.
Um, but I come up with alternative ones,
at least that student find narrative,
I guess
undervalued skill, by the
way, in some cases, right.
You gotta be careful, but, uh,
very, uh, uh, very, very, very,
very, very interesting. I, I,
I want to pause.
You're partially because I'm over
caffeinated and it was inspired by my
nostalgia related
to your double expressors up.
But why did the professor pull you aside?
What did that early undergrad
professor in logic one o one c in you,
whether he explained it or not later,
I don't know,
that led him to take a
special interest in you.
Well, I, you know, I think,
I think I was prepared in earnest
because I was mostly terrified.
Um, you know, he had a reputation
of being kind of like a, um,
you know,
he is a Socratic method teacher.
He was pretty harsh.
Um,
Colgate was very small classes and there
was a class of 80 people and he kind of
wanted to widdle it down to
a more manageable number.
And his method to do that was just
to kick your ass. And I, I remember,
I mean he probably as great as he was,
he,
I doubt he would survive starting
out at a college campus now. I mean,
I've literally,
I literally saw him like fire to
someone's notebook once when he was asking
people like examples of
how to put out a fire.
And this one guy was just
stuttering cause he was so unfair.
And so you just lose notebook
on fire and you stamped it.
And the kid threw it on the ground stamp
down. He's like, you could smother it.
And he called everyone,
he memorized every person's last name.
And it was Mr and Ms. And um, I
remember the specific day, um,
he was literally at, you know, back to
the, there's like right out of a movie.
He is back to the class writing
on a chalkboard, you know, some,
some logic problems, symbolic
logic. And um, the guy next to me,
um, uh, had no shot at getting
it right and done, done right.
And so he,
he said his name and um,
and I wrote on the paper on my
desk so he could see it, like what,
what the answer was. And then without
missing a beat or turning around,
he was like, Mister conus,
please do not help him.
There's no way in hell he could possibly
have done that without your help. And,
and this is like two or three weeks in.
Right.
And he spun around and he saw that
I didn't have my book and he said,
Mr Dakota's, where's your book? And I
said, it's at my, it's in my dorm room,
you know, professor. And he said, well, a
lot of good, it's doing you there. I said,
on the contrary, it must apparently be
doing me a lot of good there. And he said,
I'll see you after class.
So I thought I was getting kicked out
and there was like a line forming to
create office hours or like asked
to be transferred out or whatever.
And when I got to the
front, he said, follow me.
And I followed him to his office
and I swear, I mean he's, you know,
running through the fall,
New England fall.
And I thought I was going to get kicked
out of the class and when I closed the
door I turned around, he has for
you up on the desk. And he said,
where are you from? What do you
want to do here? And that was it.
He took me under his wing. I was
very fortunate. I, um, and you know,
it's like I never knew.
Here's the amazing part.
I never knew the guy liked me until 10
years after I graduated and then I was
treated like a member
of his and his funeral
30 years later. Huh. Right.
So really fascinating.
A person really fascinating,
uh, you know, uh,
a moment in my life
where, um, I don't know,
someone saw something in
me and kind of went like,
I'm going to make an investment in this
person and never asked for anything back,
you know, ever. How did you
not know that he liked you?
Did he withhold in some ways so that
you wouldn't get a big head or something
along those lines?
I did he not want to get too overly
attached to you so he wouldn't express it?
No, I, I think I was 19 years old and
I didn't know that the people you like,
you hold to a higher standard probably.
Right. Um, and so consequently,
uh, you know, I like, it was really like,
he beat the shit out of me in a good way.
You know what I mean?
He,
it's like if you have someone
who's teaching you something
and they invest their
time in you and they think you
have a chance of being good,
they work you harder than
the folks around you.
So the people that I thought he liked,
he was just being nice
too because they didn't,
he didn't think they had a chance,
you know? Yeah. He didn't care.
It wasn't invested. Yeah. And, and so
with, with me, I think it would be like,
he wouldn't be talking to
my English professor without
me even knowing and being
like, you know, that paper sucks.
He can do a lot better than that.
Give them a c on that one. And it was
just like, I was like, what's going on?
Like all of a sudden that class got
hard. I didn't know. I had no idea. Um,
and uh, it was just, it was
an interesting, uh, lucky,
fortunate place to be at that time.
So we're going to get back to the mark.
But before we do philosophy,
I'm endlessly fascinated by philosophy,
but I'm also a nerd and kind of academic
and pedantic and have spent a lot of
time in school for people
who are listening to this
who are say already in their
careers or maybe they're in their early
twenties thinking of starting a company
but are entrepreneurially
either involved or inclined,
would you suggest if they don't have any
exposure to philosophy that they read
any particular books or resources
or explore it in any way?
Or would you say actually,
you know what,
that was an intermediate
step to something else.
You would probably be better
off studying x, Y and Z.
Is there like a starter kit or something
you would recommend to folks who don't
have the philosophy exposure?
You know,
I think part of it is if you
read a book in isolation, um,
it's not as rich of an
experience as discussing those
ideas within that context.
That said,
if it's,
if you're the kind of person that
loves to read and explore ideas,
I mean there's hardly a better place.
It's a matter of finding what you enjoy.
Um, you know, I happen to love,
um, the problems of philosophy,
which Bertrand Russel wrote, um,
sort of about Victor's dines ideas,
but before Vichtenstein
published, um, and it's,
it's written in plain language.
It's not hard to understand. Um,
certainly need
Jay is more like philosophy with some
weird sugar coating of something on top of
it. Um, and man, like as
a young male, you know,
reading Nietzsche, that for
the first time, I was like,
fuck yeah. You know, like,
like,
it's not like it's that passive,
like I think people think of philosophers
as like Zen monks sitting there
quietly contemplating the
universe. Um, I think what it is,
is it's people grappling with all of
the same questions and curiosity that,
that we all have. If you pause to
think about it. And so there, it's,
it's so big, you know, um, that it's,
it's not just, you know, Descartes,
I think therefore I am, it's, it's,
it's kind of every little bit of that,
um, back to like, you know, read
Luke reaches like he had the atomic.
Could you spell that? I'm going to do this
first one to admit that increase. Yes.
Yeah. I mean, you know, he,
Luc, R, I t I. U s yeah,
I'm a terrible speller, so never asked
me to it. We'll put it in the show notes.
Right, right. But like, you
know, it's like you read,
read that or read this great book called
the swerve, which you know, is, is uh,
you know about this, this
monk ages ago. Um, that,
that sort of found that book and then
rewrote it and saved it for history.
Like that reads like a murder mystery.
Like you don't necessarily need
to start with the philosophy.
You can start with the things
around it. Um, but I, you know,
it's like I continue to find sort of the
world of ideas endlessly inspirational
and, and then by the way, you know,
steal them and use them in
whatever you're doing like that.
They're there for you.
The Cretia, Luc, r e t, I,
U s Titus Lucretius Charisse was
a Roman poet and philosopher.
We'll put that in the show notes. The,
I want to second Bertrand Russell. Also,
I haven't read Bertrand
Russell and so many ages,
but it is very digestible.
It is not dressed up in $10 words
when 10 cent words would suffice.
Uh, a lot of his writing
is, is really powerful.
And I also just wanted to
mention for folks that,
and I just thought about
this ages and ages ago,
I felt like I had certain
gaps in my education,
uh,
after college and I ended up,
I don't know why this
didn't occur to me earlier,
but somebody mentioned that Stanford,
UC Berkeley,
these top tier universities all had
extended or adult education classes taught
by professors in junior professors.
I mean these,
this is the same team
who's teaching and uh,
those are very readily accessible.
Well and even MIT open courseware,
like so many colleges now have
taken that model and put great,
great classes online.
Um,
and I know that every now and
then I'm surprised what I,
what I find on there and get
sucked into like an all nighter of,
of taking some college class, you
know, that I know nothing about.
And it's so far over my head, but it
kind of refuels you again to go like, oh,
like there are huge gaps
where I know nothing.
And the older you get,
the harder it is to,
to start into something
new, I find at least, um,
because it feels like the
mountains too big. You know,
I would, I would actually,
uh, not, not to pull a nick.
Actually on the contrary,
on the contrary, sir,
my book is doing me a lot
of good in my dorm room.
I think one of your superpowers is that
you ask the fundamental why questions
about long standing assumptions or a
conventional wisdom in different fields.
And the more you have done that,
the more obvious it is to you
to do it as a starting point,
uh, in, in a way. So let's
go back to the Merck. Uh, we,
we can go in any direction
of course, but yeah, you,
you get used to step into this lord of
the flies slash gladiatorial arena with
butchers and phd.
He is and so on.
Then what like at what point is
there a point when you're like, okay,
I actually do think I
could be good at this?
No, I for real, no,
I was down there and I,
I had made a fatal error of leaving
school and everyone told me it was a fatal
error and um, this is leading the
little school. Yeah. And, and I,
I,
I remember being down there and you know,
what I was doing was so brainless.
It was literally you take this piece of
paper over to that guy and then that guy
would yell at you and you'd rip the paper
out of your hand and then you go get
another one.
It was literally that dead
and I was desperately looking
to learn what was going
on around me.
Um,
and of course I bought books on finance
and commodities and options and all that
and they were completely ridiculous and
opaque and academic that it looked like
they had no relationship to what
was going on there at all. Um,
I started taking classes that were run
at the merch on mock trading and just
learning the hand signals
and things like that,
which were fine but didn't
really teach you how to trade.
And I spent time interviewing with big
companies like Goldman Sachs and society
in general and whatnot because I did have
the academic background where I would
get the interview,
I would be able to take the test,
I would do well in their
math and psychology tests.
I would get offered a job as a trader.
Uh,
and then I would look at the contract.
This is a key thing people get out
of college to get offered a job.
I think I'm the only one who ever
read the employment contract.
And what it said in there was basically
like they can do anything they want with
me for three years. Like I don't even
necessarily need to be a trader like I,
that's why I was interested in doing,
but they could,
they could ship me to France and have
me do something totally different.
I can be an analyst or you know,
God knows what.
And so when I would question
that, there'd be like, man,
you should be really happy.
Like,
we had 300 applicants for
this and we offered eight
positions, like just take it.
And I was kind of like totally your style,
kind of like, you know, I,
I grew up, you know, like,
I'd be remiss not to say
that like my dad modeled, um,
my dad was an entrepreneur by necessity
because his dad died when he was really
young.
He fought both at the end of World War II.
He was drafted into the navy
at the end of World War Two,
was dismissed honorably after 16,
18 months because they
were downsizing the navy.
And then he was barely young enough to
be drafted into the army for the Korean
War. And when he got out, like,
you know, he had no usable skills.
So he went to work at the grocery store
that he started working at when he was
12 years old,
save the ball of his money from the
army and the navy and bought the store.
And so as I was growing up, uh, you know,
my hero was my dad who was not
an academic, who was not, um,
what people would think of as like
an executive and a suit or whatever,
but did really well. Um,
you know, he had, uh, uh,
bought property in real estate.
He,
he owned a temporary labor office that's
applied on skilled laborers to factory
and conventions and whatnot. Um, that
was a really good business, you know,
and he had a lot of common sense smarts.
Um,
he was horrified that I didn't
go to law school, you know,
but meanwhile I was modeling what he did.
And so when I got down there,
I was like, you got to own, you have to
own your own situation, you know? Um,
and so when I was offered
those jobs, I was like, well,
I don't really see myself working
for someone else, you know?
And I found a guy who also felt that
way and he was working for a big company
and they didn't want to make him a trader
because he was too much of a quant.
Like he was really well educated.
He was really mathematical.
He wanted to prove them wrong.
So he took a small amount of money
and started trading currency options.
And when I found him,
I instantly knew that this was the right
person because I talked to dozens of
people and no one was like him.
And then he said he didn't want to hire
me. Like, do you want to hire anyone?
How did you meet him?
Do you remember how you guys,
I was just introduced to him through, he
was back then, they were, you know, it's,
if you're a trader, um,
or even a trading company,
you have a clearing firm
like Goldman Sachs. Um,
at the time there was a company
called first options, um,
and he cleared first options and back
then you literally have to take the
elevator up to keep punching in all of
the cards into like a computer that was,
you know, up on 17 floors away.
Um, you know, wow. Ancient Times.
And uh, I met him through, uh,
being introduced to him there. Uh,
after talking to him, I knew he was
a sort of Geeky intellectual that I,
that I needed.
Um,
and then when he told me that he didn't
want to hire me cause he just heard some
clerk, I was like, no, no, no,
no, no, like I will pay you
to work for you. And he was,
he was like, this is really strange,
you know. And I explained to him,
like I said, it's like I look up video
six months, I set a goal for myself of,
of getting, you know, becoming
like getting on a badge.
It was called like leasing a seat
and actually trading within a year.
And I was like,
I need to get going on this.
Like I need someone that's going
to teach me options. And um,
it's fascinating because, you know,
he, he then hired me for, I mean,
I want to say it was $400 a week or
something like that. And, uh, you know,
I stood right next to him all day,
every day and he taught me options,
theory from scratch,
better than any college ever could.
Um, to the point where you're looking,
you know, three derivatives
in, um, you know,
the such as volatility curve
but the curve of the curve and,
um, you know, as soon as I started
grasping this and going deeper,
deeper down that rabbit hole, the more,
the more I liked it as, as a puzzle.
It wasn't certainly the money
had an appeal, but it was also,
hey, here's this, this giant competition.
It's like paying a huge multifaceted
chess game that no one's going to get.
Exactly right.
But like I said earlier,
it's about making hundreds
of decisions a day.
And even when you get 10 in a row
that come up, tails, you know,
that the next one's 50,
50, you know, and uh,
that discipline was interesting.
That was more about teaching yourself
the psychology of standing there while
everyone told you you were wrong or you
were like physically small or you are
too educated or too serious.
I mean,
you can't imagine how much of a
fraternity house that place was.
I everything in Wolf of Wall Street,
I've seen,
I haven't lived, but I've seen
it all. Yeah. And, um, you know,
I started hiring very shortly
after I started trading.
And about a year later I left and started
my own company with almost nothing.
And I hired my first employee who became
my business partner for the last 25
years.
And I taught him what I,
what I learned and I hired people
that I considered corporate refugees,
um,
people who worked for companies and
decided that independence was better.
Why did you leave after
a year? Um, you know, he,
he was moving over to the Chicago Board
of trade and I had found a couple of
awesome programmers, um, to help
build this options analysis software.
And he sort of offered me up,
um,
to run like some of the operations at
the Mercantile Exchange when he went over
to trade the bonds at the board of trade.
And, you know, I mean, he was really,
really smart guy and he,
he made me a deal that when
you analyzed it very carefully,
you got worse over time. And I just
kind of went, you know, I like,
it's been great and I've learned a ton
and we've made each other a bunch of
money and it's a win win.
But I really wanted to do my own thing.
Like I want it to be the captain
of my own ship I guess. And uh,
thankfully this Guy Jim Hansen who is
still one of my dearest friends, um,
sort of had an option to,
to stay with that company or come at
it completely underfunded company.
I mean, thinking back, it was so stupid,
you know, um, from a risk perspective.
But um, it was asymmetric, you know,
I'm far more upside than downside and uh,
it worked out really well and we spent
most of our time as we hired people and
taught them how to do this.
It was mostly like psychology training.
It was mostly standing around after hours
and saying what's seven times 28 and
screaming at each other like
a drill sergeant until the
person couldn't remember
what nine times three was anymore.
And wait,
why didn't you do that
while you had to be quick?
You have to be quick on
basic mental agility.
If you bought 450 contracts
and it was a 20 delta,
you needed to be able to do
what's 20% of four 50. It's 90,
but you need to do that precisely
with numbers that are not so round.
Right.
Uh,
you need to be willing to not be perfect
and you need to make that decision
instantaneously and realizing that it
could cost you 50 to a hundred thousand
dollars if you get it right or wrong
and you, and you have to be really,
really comfortable with that.
Um,
and so what did we do while
we stood around and we'd be,
we turned people's brains
into mush until like,
literally I've had people punch
me, cry, run out. It was, um,
it was, no, I mean, it
sounds awful, but it was,
it's amazing training because the
rest of the world moves much slower.
So any other decisions that I've
made in business since then, um,
have felt glacial in pace. Yeah. Um,
and also
something to be said for
making the trainer the training
in some or all respects
harder than the
competition. Right? I mean,
the adage of the more you
sweat during peace time,
the less you bleed during
war time. I mean, the,
the best competitors I've met in many,
many fields often strive to make
their training and the toil of their
preparation harder than what they
expect to face when they actually,
that's why we love watching big time
sports. Like when it, when it matters,
there are certain people
that you know, are, are,
you can almost look at them and go,
ah,
at port that port person's gonna fade
and then you, you hope they don't. Right.
You hope all that training, you know,
pays off. Um, when you see someone,
I love golf for all the same
reasons. It's like, you know, just a,
a series of constant
failures. And then, so, um,
when you look at someone who, who can
pull that rabbit out of the hat, you know,
at the exactly the right
moment, um, it's, it's pretty,
pretty wonderful to see. And, and I, the
thing I loved about my time down there,
even though I burned out of it
after 10 years, is that I, uh,
there were moments where I did
absolutely, I mean, I have friends,
they'll listen to this and
they'll be like, oh yeah, I
remember that time, the Sop,
but you really get this
right. And, um, but I,
I made some completely
stupid decisions. Um, but,
but mostly on the measure,
um, when things got crazy,
I was able to perform more than not.
I remember like Greenspan's irrational
exuberance speech was like a formative
moment where I kind of went
like, wow, I can actually,
I can not only hang in this environment,
I can thrive in it. And, you know,
you get home soaking wet with sweat.
It was a physical job like as a people,
it was really blue collar and
a lot of ways and um, you know,
it's like I got home that
day and I was like, that was,
that was what I prep my last six
years for. It was very satisfying.
It sounds like an awful, it is an awful
thing in a way. Right. Like, it's,
it's just about pure commerce. Um, it, it,
it serves a purpose of price
discovery and all of that.
But any individual person isn't
really the one doing that, you know?
So I think that there are negatives to
the whole system as well in hindsight.
But man, at the time it just
felt like great mental training.
What would you recommend to people
who are listening and are having this
flashback to the introductory
text exchange about beating
the market over a long
period of time who are hoping
to become better investors?
And you can take that anywhere you want,
but are there any particular
tools through mental models?
Anything that you would recommend?
Really, really hard. Um,
I think the mental model
is asymmetric risk.
I always look for something that
the, the upside is, you know,
three to four x the downside.
Um,
obviously quantifying those is very
difficult. Um, but that's, that's the key.
Everything I tried to do is asymmetric.
Um,
and then even though I'm Nesson Taleb
is a bit of a pen Dantic goofball on
Twitter, um, his book fooled
by randomness is awesome. Yeah.
That was the one that proceeded Black
Swan. And, um, I think black swans great.
It's fine. But, um,
fooled by randomness is,
is I think the better of all his
books because it, it just, man,
it just encapsulates everything that
people price things incorrectly.
It's have to casino. Yeah. Yeah.
You Walk through a casino and you see
everybody pricing their outcomes and
correctly the entire city is
built on that. And um, you know,
if you could get in your head,
literally, literally, yeah. Literally.
And I don't take any pleasure. Like
people are like, oh, you must do,
you must love gambling or whatever.
And it's like I would never sit down to
a blackjack table because I know that,
you know,
there's a 49 and a half percent chance
that I'm going to win and that's the
wrong way. Yeah. Yeah.
The fuller randomness is, uh,
has come up a number of times.
I haven't read it in ages because it
is one of his earlier books, but, uh,
you know,
Howard marks also brought this up
recently when I was chatting with him and,
uh,
it is an exceptional book.
I think for developing a new lens on life,
not just investing when you
are investing for yourself now,
how do you think about,
how do you think about risk,
because this is a word that has popped
up a few times, uh, but a lot of,
uh,
how do you proceed?
How do you personally think
about risk in your life? Do you,
for instance,
like some startup founders look at the
risk as the various early stage startups,
restaurants,
bars,
and so on that you're involved with and
then you play it safe in your other kind
of asset allocation.
How do you think about risk in,
in your life or in investing?
Yeah,
it's pretty difficult question.
Yeah, I think that, um,
if you look at everything
that I've done business wise,
everybody would say that the failure
rate is super high in what we do.
So trading these to say one out of a
hundred people that goes down there at
breaks,
even their first year and fewer out of,
out of that one take another hundred
of those ones and less than one in a
hundred of those becomes a
millionaire. And I went, great.
It's like the old Jim Carrey. So you're
saying there's chance, you know? Right.
You know, and, and uh,
and then you go to, uh, to the
restaurant business and people, oh yeah.
95% of all the restaurants go out of
business and their first two years,
and I'm like, going great. You know,
that's, that's perfect. Um, why do you,
why do you have that response?
Is it because then I'm going to start,
I'm doing a software startup now.
Go for it.
So the higher the smaller the hoop,
um, the more interesting
it is to figure it out.
Um,
and once you're up there and you know
how to jump up through that little hoop,
um, there's, there's fewer people
playing that game, you know?
And,
and the other thing is,
I remember right when I was going to
start building Alinea with, with grant,
I was talking to a restaurant owner.
And by all accounts he was
pretty successful. He had
four or five restaurants,
and one of them I really liked a lot.
And we'd go there a lot and I kinda got
to know him a little bit. And he said,
so you know, what are
you up to? And I said,
well actually I'm building a restaurant
now. And he looked at me, said, ah,
it's a terrible business. You don't want
to do it, like incredible failure rate.
Terrible. And I was like, why
did you build the next four?
What did you, how did you respond
to that? You know, no one does.
That's kind of like, you know,
we'll get to it, I'm sure.
But that's like the way I was with the
publishing thing. It's like, it's like,
hey man,
people keep printing books and yet I
can't figure out any of the information.
And yet they're going to give me like
three or $400,000 to write a book.
Like somethings remiss here.
Like, you know what I mean?
I've never written a book before,
but yet someone's going to pay me $400,000
check is there must be a lot of money
on the other side of that bet.
And, um, and so consequently you,
like I always try to look for the high
small hoops and then I spend my time
learning as much as I can and
then I jump through that hoop.
It's both more interesting I think.
And I also think getting back
to the asymmetry of risk, um,
those are the ones that, you know,
yeah, you might have a, you know,
well first of all,
do you really have a 95% failure rate
if you put in all that effort? Yeah,
I don't think so. You know? Um,
and second of all, you know,
so I think they priced it wrong so to
speak. Um, and then second of all, like,
man, that's, that's where the fun is.
Like that gets you up in the
morning and going to work.
Yeah. Yeah. This is, this
is where, uh, in among many,
many other places, averages
can be very, very misleading.
Right. And, uh,
I always end up in public Q and
A's and things of this type,
hearing various numbers
and stats thrown around,
many of which I think have no basis on
any data whatsoever. But there's the,
we only use 10% of our brands,
not true.
There is the nine out of 10 startups fail
within the first year or whatever the
stat is stat is.
And the first question that occurs
to me with a number like the,
uh, the ladder or I
guess a ratio is, well,
is it because the model is difficult?
Is it because startups are
inherently that high risk or is it,
is,
are there other plausible explanations?
Is it that nine out of 10 people who
attempt to start a startup don't do any of
the necessary due diligence?
Correct.
Yeah. I mean the number of the number of,
I, you know, I've been on a couple of, uh,
like graduate school, you
know, entrepreneurship, um,
like you know,
contests and whatnot.
And one of the things that always
happens there is what I call,
like the time machine. Someone comes
up with a business plan that is like,
you know, you know, I'm going
to build a time machine.
Now of course it's not really a time
machine, but I have seen ones at defy,
the laws of physics for
example. Um, or, you know,
new pipeline technology, but they have
no idea. Like it's just a pipe dream.
They've done none of the
engineering, you know. Um, so you,
you kind of look at that and you go,
you know,
you haven't really done the
homework yet at all. Um,
and then there's a lot of people that
come to me and they've spent like six
months doing their logo and
the name of the company,
but they don't actually have a
piece of software yet. Right.
I'm just going to hire someone to
build that for me or I'm an APP. Uh,
y'all get so many apps
pitch to me and you know,
they don't know how to build an APP,
but they've got a logo in an idea.
And I was like, that's a good way to blow
a half million dollars in a consultant.
Oh Man, I, we're going to get
all that. You must get that
50 times worse than I. Uh,
I need to,
what I tend to get,
and this is part of the reason why
I stopped all the startup stuff, uh,
a couple of years ago,
is it got to the point where
90% of the pitches I received,
which were unsolicited
would be along the lines of,
uh, hi comma, like not even a
first name or it'd be like, Hi Tim,
or hate him even better.
Uh,
I am the CEO or cofounder of X. Uh,
we are raising this at this valuation.
We are oversubscribed,
but we could squeeze you in and for 25
k if you're really interested because we
admire of ABC, uh,
here, the docs attached,
let us know if your interest
in the next 60 minutes,
which I ended up my default response
to anything like that where people are
pressuring me for a fast decision is
no. Like, it's just a, it's like I've,
I've lost very little money saying
no to those things. Um, but the,
the goal coming back to the,
the examples that you were giving
and what we were talking about, uh,
bridging over to restaurants and food.
Um,
so you're, you're being told how
restaurants are an awful business.
Food is an awful business. And I remember
someone told me long, long time ago,
they were like, Yep, if you want to lose
money, go into magazines or restaurants.
Right.
And at what point,
and I have a little bit of the backstory,
but not all the details,
like at what point do you decide to go
into or get involved with restaurants and
why?
Well, so I, I left trading
in about 2002, um, 2001,
uh,
knew it was a tough year between nine 11,
which was my father had died in February
of that year. Um, I was burnt out after,
you know, going really hard
for so long and um, you know,
we'd built up a pretty
good size company too.
And I merged with a firm
in New York and I just,
I kind of needed a break
but didn't know how to,
how to really take one at
the time. Um, and so I left,
I left trading and I immediately
kind panicked because here's
something that I,
I really genuinely enjoyed but didn't,
didn't kind of know what I wanted to do
next and started doing consulting for a
small hedge fund and, and then, you know,
I just didn't know what to
do. And I, I had, you know,
an awesome wife and a young son
and things were good, you know,
but I was kind of panicked. I was, I
was playing golf with like, you know,
ex athletes because who else is 34 years
old and complete golf on a Wednesday
afternoon.
Um,
and so it was just a weird thing and I
kind of looked at them and I'm like, oh,
they don't really seem all that happy,
even though they're,
they've got this lifestyle. And so, um,
I met grant Achatz, um, the
chef, uh, at dwell dining,
a trio,
um,
went to a lunch there one afternoon
that some friends set up and it was a
transformative experience. It was
artistic, it was intellectual,
it was thought provoking.
Most of all,
it was emotional and those are all
things that I would never have associated
with eating at dinner.
Right. Um, and so from,
from a perspective of like
great art experiences,
like seeing a great movie or a great play
or going to an amazing museum opening,
um,
we kept getting drawing back there,
like we kept going back and we would go
back so frequently that it was absurd
because, you know, as a big
meal and it wasn't cheap.
And every time we'd go somewhere
else, we'd go like, wow, why are,
why is no one else thinking this way?
And as I got to know grants a little bit,
I think like sometimes
people bring, um, you know,
the chefs and wine or beer or whatever,
and it's like,
that's kind of sand to the
beach. You know, I would,
I would bring him books and I didn't
figure he had a lot of time to read.
So I would put like a post it
note on a page of an old book.
So I remember I brought him this book
called the peregrinations of an epicure.
Hold on. It's like the peregrinations,
like a Peregrine Falcon.
I don't even know what that
paragraph nation is like a
wondering about. Uh, okay.
So it was written just after World
War Two, um, by an ex servicemen. Um,
and he, he kind of goes
around, um, you know, Paris,
I want to say maybe late forties, early
fifties. I can't recall exactly. And,
uh, there was, um, a chapter in
there, unloved pair Meade, uh,
which was a very classical restaurant,
kind of the best in the world at the time.
And he described to me a meal there in
emotional terms that resonated with what
grant was doing, even though
his technique, his cuisine,
everything was completely different.
And so I literally just highlight like a
couple lines in there and give him this
book, which was out of
print at the time. And, um,
we kind of developed this
email relationship back and
forth where he would sort
of try out some new food down
us. And, um, I would give,
you know, direct, honest feedback,
but not like, oh, it was delicious.
It was more or less, it was
more like the, you know,
like you're going for a provocation
there, but if you, you know,
and we would go back and forth
and he wrote a, at the time on a,
on a forum called Eagle it.
Uh,
and I went down there and his spelling
and grammar, not with standing.
I mean it was like reading someone who's
just really thinking hard about what
they were doing.
Everything we just talked about here
was this young 28 year old chef from
Michigan who looked like captain America
who would come out, not, you know,
he was like how you would
in the sense of like,
he was good looking and very driven,
very clean cut, but he didn't look like,
you know, the stereotype central casting
of a chef. Right. You know, Chubby,
gregarious guy. He was really
quiet and introspective, shy.
But then you read and you know these
which are still up, you know, I,
you can still Google it and you'd go like,
you know,
he'd go on for like four
pages about bread service.
Like what's the point of bread?
You know,
and this is the kind that I could
wrap my head around. And so, um,
I remember on January 20th, 2004, uh,
it's my wife's birthday and she
said, yeah, I want to go back there.
And we'd never been in the kitchen
before and they have a table there,
but we never eaten in there. And, um,
I remember I emailed him and said,
she's ethnically Latvian,
speaks Japanese and loves Thai food.
Good fucking luck.
And I knew exactly what that would do
to them that would put into 10 days of
pure hell because he human
research Latvian food,
he would have to read, like he would
redo a whole menu, 20 courses. Right.
And I didn't know they were going
to put us in the kitchen. And, um,
they put us in the kitchen. I mean, it
sounds like a jerky thing to do now,
but we did have a relationship a little
bit at the time and he served us like
the most amazing meal of
my life, you know. Um,
and it started out with Latvians
sorrel soup with braised ham hocks,
and, you know, it had flavors of the
sea, which was a Japanese dish. It had,
it had Thai dishes, it, but
it was all in his style.
And so it was his own, and yet it
had elements of all these things.
And at the end of that meal, um, he said
to me, you know, well, what do you think?
And I'd watched the kitchen and
it was like a watchmaker shop.
It was not screaming and yelling.
It is, it is just as it is.
So unlike anything that the vast majority
of people listening to this would
possibly expect, right. Ramsay
Gordon Ramsay, right? Yeah.
It is just complete silence. It is
like a watchmaking factory. It is.
Uh, it is really something
else. Anyway, I started to jump
in. Yeah, no, no, no. It's,
it's, that's, that's totally fine.
And so at the end I said, you know,
I doubt anybody anywhere in the world had
a better meal tonight. And he was like,
well, well, thank you. And I said, what
are you planning on doing with yourself?
You know, I mean, I was like kind of,
I had a lot of wine and I kind
of looked at him, you know,
he down with us and I said, what do you,
what are you going to do? And he goes,
well, what do you mean? I said, well,
you're not going to be here forever.
And he said, well, I want to build
my own restaurant. I said, I'd be,
I'd be happy to help you
do that. And he said, well,
what kind of restaurant do you want
to build? I said, I don't know.
I've never built a restaurant before.
That was it.
And then like a week later I got an email
with his business plan and I invited
him by my house in a year to the day
later of that. That was May 4th. Um,
you know, I, we went back and
forth on email on May 4th,
we held a dinner at my house
for potential investors.
And on May 4th,
2005,
we opened Alinea is nuts in
terms of each other that,
can you put that in
perspective for people?
I actually did not realize that was the,
the timeframe.
Yeah. I mean, can you just in the
context of like normal restaurant world,
we argued like, so we didn't
really know each other very well,
but he would come by my house and he,
and he didn't let, let me, let me,
let me interject for a
second because you've,
you've said we didn't
know each other very well.
What did you know about each other
nonetheless that gave you guys the,
like the push,
like the impulse and the,
the sufficient level of trust slash
excitement to actually pursue it.
Right. There had to be something
there. It couldn't just be nothing.
So what was it, you didn't
know each other? Well, I mean,
you maybe you didn't know the full scope
of each other's back thoughts. Yeah,
I mean, I actually studied that like,
that I actually knew I knew the facts,
you know, um, and I knew what he
was putting in front of me. Um,
but I didn't know him,
you know,
like the way you know someone that
you're going to become a business partner
with. Um, and I think he
just thought I was rich.
I'd be curious
like I think everyone else wanted this is,
this is really true cause
he has said this to me. Um,
everyone else wanted to offer him a,
a restaurant that they had
already built or wanted to build.
And I actually answered that
question correctly. The,
I don't know is an awesome thing to say,
like 90% of the time for your life.
Right. And so when he said, what can
a restaurant do you want to build?
I could have waxed on about some dream
I had or just made some bullshit up at
the time. But I just said like, I have
no idea. Like we, that's a big question.
We need to sort that out. Um, and I
think that was the right answer for him.
I think that's all he needed
to know. It was like, okay,
the guy's got an open mind. He seems to
have done well in business. He knows like,
you know, apparently how
to build something. Well,
it was really funny is that the
stuff that I was concerned about,
which was like architecture, design,
plumbing, you know, building,
lease, all of that. He was like,
the word oblivious is not too strong
of a word. Um, like, you know,
this is not a criticism of him either,
right?
It's just like he came to my house and
he was just like, yeah, I, you know,
I want Martin to design everything. And
Martin Kastner, who is a genius designer,
has crucial detail, which we've been
involved with for 15 years now. Um,
he's a, like a designer. He's
like, uh, uh, an artisan,
like he built plateware and
he wanted the book who's to,
or for the platter he
designed for Thomas Keller,
Daniel Boulud's team for the team USA
and all that. Now, but back then, like,
I mean, this guy's not gonna
design plumbing or electrical.
So I would just look at them
going like, well, no, he can't.
We need an architect and you need to get,
you know,
like city stamps and all that and all
that. So, um, I think grant was just like,
yeah, you find a place, you
put tables in it and you know,
build a kitchen and you go,
um, you know, in terms of like,
obviously he knew that her
health inspectors and all that,
but the process of all this just about,
you know,
you either were going to not build it
ever eight weeks in because we would have
hated each other where we really kind of
people that figured everything out and
we just talked it out like right
down to like, what kind of tables,
what kind of glass where, what
kind of this like, you know,
we wanted to rethink the
why again if everything,
like why do you put a candle on the table?
Why is it candle romantic?
Like that's a question we asked. Why do
we need candles? That's kind of like,
why is that romantic? Why is, um,
why do people put a little
bud vase on the table?
Why shouldn't that be an edible
thing? That'd be cool. So,
so we did all of that and we designed
the experience to create emotional
responses from the moment that
you walked in the front door.
So we didn't have the podium.
Um, you know, we went,
what is a good greeting feel
like not just, you know,
if you're at someone's house, what does
that feel like if you're at a restaurant,
what shouldn't it feel like?
Well,
it shouldn't feel like a computer in front
of your face saying, what's your name?
You know, and all that. So we, we went
through every aspect of that and no,
I lost almost 20 pounds that year. Not
in a healthy way. Um, just like, gee,
seeing the construction,
I laid tile in the basement like
three days before we open. Let me,
let me pause for one second.
So the why question that comes to
mind for me is after the finance,
after battling it out on the front
lines and going through 2001,
why this as your next thing? Like, why,
why was this the thing that captured your
imagination as you had to know on some
level once you started getting into
the details? Like, fuck, I mean,
this is going to be, yeah, it's
all in. This has to be a big,
this is going to be all my chips
and energetically. So why, why this,
you know,
there,
there are occasional times when you
wake up in the morning and like,
that thought comes back to you
that, that like, hey, um, you know,
I'm, I'm, I'm really sucked
into this. Right. You know,
and for about three or four
months without telling anybody,
even like, even not telling
her, like, telling no one,
I kept going like,
I should build a restaurant with this guy.
Like it would be the best restaurant in
the world if it was done all the way.
Right.
And I recognized my inner voice saying,
that's a really dumb idea. You know,
and you don't know what you're doing.
I'd never worked a day in my life
and a restaurant. Right. And,
and I also recognized,
and this is also critical,
I recognized that so many people built
their living room after they made some
money. So they went like, oh,
well I know how to host a good
dinner party and I know good wine,
so I'm going to build me a restaurant.
And then they sit there like it's
their living room. And that's not good.
Like I didn't want to be that, that
DC guy that built the restaurant, um,
because my ego was needed to host a party.
Um,
and so whenever I would kind of lead her
on broach that subject and people would
say like, well, you know, I can
almost hear their brain whispering,
well of course that's what
he's going to do. And, and,
and so that was again, not the best
of motivations in the world perhaps,
but the honest one that was
hugely motivating. Um, eventually,
but when we first started,
it was this nagging thing.
Like I'd wake up in the morning
and I would go, you know,
I'm not really into what
I'm doing right now,
and I've just met somebody
who's the best in the world.
At what they do and no one knows
it yet. Like, and, and you know,
it was probably met.
That's probably happened to be,
I'm really fortunate that that's probably
happened to be seven or eight times in
my life. And when it happens and I
meet that person, whoever it may be,
no matter what they're
doing, I, I, I pause,
I kind of acknowledged that directly and
then I just go like, you know, can we,
can we,
you know,
grab a glass of wine or coffee or
something and like that's something worth
marking and going like, wow, this
person's really invested in something.
And grant had every aspect of being,
being that at 28 years old.
And, and it, I, you know,
I mean in hindsight, like it looks,
it looks smart, but I got to tell you,
it was years before it felt smart
because you mentioned just now that
you've met these people seven or eight
times, who are the best in the world, uh,
or potentially the best thing, most
of them among them. But the, the, the,
the key point that jumps
out for me is in the world,
didn't know it yet.
So my question for you is that,
that sort of brings to the forefront,
in my mind,
at least the question of what is Nick's
seeing or feeling that other people are
not. Could you talk to that? And I mean,
is there a feeling or a
particular type of observation,
a particular type of detail that you
noticed in these people that allows you to
scout the talent where other people might
miss it or not pay enough attention to
it? Yeah, I mean, I think you've
written a couple about, about that.
Um, it's, it's, it's definitely
intangible. Um, you know,
it's, I think it's
different in every case. Um,
but it's,
it's interesting because you can
tell when someone is fully committed,
I guess to their craft or their art or
their business or whatever it is that
they're doing their sport.
Um, and it's not because they,
they talk it about it all the time
though. Of course, you know, if you,
if you push a little,
they're happy to do so.
But it's more that like
if you look around,
like the vast majority of people are not
fully committed to whatever, you know,
and I think part of what you do is you
try to steer people to find those things
that,
that they can commit to,
or you can try to lower a
barrier to show them like, hey,
the commitment's not as hard as you think
in this particular area. Right. Right.
But these folks are like,
they're all in their 99%,
and that's what they do often
to the detriment, frankly, of,
of other aspects of their lives.
Um,
and I guess you get better
at noticing them, you know?
Um, and I mean now, like that's like,
boy, I live for that. Like
I love meeting people that,
um,
even if it's not something I'm
interested in that are all in, you know,
and, and that's, that's an
interesting, you know, I really,
I've never really thought
about it that way, but like,
it was this very clear to me
that grant was all in. Like,
if, here's the thing, if,
if he wasn't gonna do it with me, he
was still gonna do it. Yeah, I was,
I was, uh, I was a helper. I, you know,
over time I certainly contributed,
um, you know, a great deal to it,
not just he contributed a
great deal of the business.
And then I also contributed to the
art, but that took time, you know,
but I could tell that he was all
in and, and that was fun. I mean,
it's fun to work with somebody
who is basically like, okay man,
if you're not in like get out of the way.
Cause I'm still going [inaudible]
and for anyone who has the opportunity,
I don't even know if they would
have the opportunity, but to watch,
observe grant even for 60 seconds.
Well,
chef's table on Netflix is a
great chef's table. Yeah. Perfect.
So everybody should have the experience
of observing grant working and focusing.
It is. I've, I've met a lot of
people who are good at focusing,
who have abnormal focusing abilities and
spending the time that we did together
in Chicago and the time that
I had to observe grant is,
it is a next level of focus. It's, it's
really hard to encapsulate and words.
So chef's table, fantastic people
should check it out. And just
the level of focus that is
permeates the appearance,
the air, the atmosphere. It's
really something else. Uh,
so to,
to to to that point focus,
one of the,
my favorite aspects of,
of speaking with you and having
conversations is the question,
the questions that you raised,
right? Like what candle?
Not just should we have candles?
Like that's maybe a good question,
but it's probably not
the right first question.
Like why do restaurants use candles
in the first place? Furthermore,
wire candles consider romantic, right?
Like kind of stepping basic basic stuff.
Yeah.
What are other questions that you
asked related to a linea or you,
he can certainly bridge to two other,
uh, you know, I think it makes sense to,
to chat about aviary as well. But what
are, what are some other questions that,
that you guys asked
that, uh, people might,
might not think to ask?
Yeah, I mean, it, you know, grants at the
tone for that. Um, in our first meeting,
not really knowing me
and we started talking,
but we didn't even know
where to start. Right? And he
said, well, I know one thing,
I want to have wooden tables,
like I want to have bare wood tables.
And I said, why? He said, well,
why do tables while your fancy
restaurants have white tablecloths?
They literally call it a white
tablecloth restaurant if it's fancy. Why?
And I couldn't really, I came
up with dumb answers like, oh,
it feels good or it absorbs like
a spill or whatever it may be. Um,
and he said, no, it's because of the
table underneath as a piece of shit.
And he's like, he goes, and you know
that like, as soon as you say it,
everyone goes, oh yeah, I knew that.
And you've been at weddings and stuff
where you feel under the table and you're
like, oh, it's plywood. Right? But if
you go to like a really fancy restaurant,
you feel under the table, guess what? Also
applied with just a little thicker. Um,
and he's like, you know, when
you rest your arms on the table,
even if it doesn't come
forefront in your mind,
you kind of subconsciously
know that they're kind of
fooling you. And he's like,
why can't we just have like
black beautiful tables?
It'll show the food grade,
they'll show the plate where great.
And then I kind of went like,
well, yeah, but like, you know, um,
the health department doesn't
let you put in Chicago,
doesn't let you put silverware right
on the table. And if you put a glass,
they're the kind of sensational form,
a little ring,
and then you have a wear issue.
Um,
but you'll save $70,000 a
year in laundering linens.
And so we started going like, well, how
did we solve the water problem? Well,
you create a fridge that's just above
the duty point 44 degrees in the winter,
maybe a little warmer in the
summer because it's higher
humidity in Chicago and
you just get rid of ice.
It's, you know, it says,
so you have these cascading decisions
that like become part of the art of the
place that some of them start from like
a really practical thing. Like, Hey,
we want to have a table.
And then all of a sudden you need a
little pillow that the silverware goes on
because that Martin designed,
because you can't put,
we didn't want to have
place mats that's too cheap.
So all of a sudden we had to design
like, you know, a silverware holder.
So it just became this cascade of
like interesting little art projects,
um,
that were there for good reasons and
really created a unique atmosphere.
And it was like one of the things,
like we never tested it
until the day we opened.
Like you couldn't test those things.
And the very first guy through the
door was, um, is now a famous chef,
chef Sean Brock of husk
plastic. Yeah. So he was,
he was not yet a chef then 2005,
and he was the first guy through the door
and he wrote this giant blog post and
eagle it with pictures and everything.
You can go see it.
And every single thing that we hoped
would create an emotional trigger,
an emotional reaction, it's
almost at all. They're like,
I remember going home and seeing that
the next day and going, wow, like,
that should actually work,
you know,
and it's like right down to the
front hallway that was, you know,
a reverse perspective and, you know,
stolen from sharp cathedral and,
and an inverted, you know, um,
so all of my interests of architecture
and art and science and all of grants,
you know,
food and all that,
like all came together in like a year
long conversation on how to do something.
And we really fought with the architect
and designers and all of that because
people would tell us the practical
reasons why you needed to do this or that.
And we would just go, nope,
no host Dan. Like, you know,
we want to greet people
in a, in an open way. Um,
and so just little things like that. And
then we've taken that on, you know, um,
through everything that we've,
we've done where we took, you know,
seven years,
six years to,
to build our next place because we
didn't have that idea that kept us up at
night again. Um, and so,
you know, when we did,
then we did it. And I
think, I think editing,
editing yourself and each other
is in an open way is really,
really painful, but
really, really important.
And coming back to something you
mentioned relate to the living room,
uh, the, uh, the well off, uh, yes.
Who then create saying art
project that is not, uh,
may be beautiful,
but is most often not a viable business.
What,
how did you apply those questions and
rethink the business model to make any of
this work financially? Yeah. Well, I mean,
you don't want to be a dill town, right?
Um, and, and so, you know,
my biggest fear is that,
um,
it would work
in an artistic way, but
wouldn't work as a business. Uh,
and so, you know, the, the, the answer is,
at the beginning we didn't,
I didn't do much. Um,
I handled all of our marketing and PR,
like I wrote everything,
you know, myself. Um,
really thought about open sourcing the,
the building of the restaurant.
Um,
you can still go on line and see that the
original business plans and what logos
we were considering using and to the
test kitchen, which was in my house.
You know,
we didn't tell anyone at the time,
but that was my house at the time and,
and see the development
of this restaurant. Um,
and I felt like the open
source movement in that way,
it was a good model for what we
were trying to, to accomplish.
And part of that was people
would say like a restaurant,
like this can't make money.
And you know,
I wrote this little spreadsheet that
I called the universal restaurant
calculator and can people
find that online? No, no,
no. But it would be very unimpressive.
Um, if they could. But it was,
it was basically like how
many covers per night.
I mean this is back of the envelope stuff.
How many covers per night can you do?
What's the check average for
food check every for beverage.
What are your food costs, beverage
costs, labor costs was insurance costs,
you know, your, your lease, your rent,
like all those things. Right. Um,
and I had enough experience with most
of those things to at least give good
estimates to it.
And so I started doing is I started
modeling other restaurants using the
universal restaurant calculator.
And um, I had, again,
this goes to the transparency of data.
I had real data for only two restaurants
and from those two I would then make
assumptions about restaurants like the
French laundry where grant used to work.
Well, while the greatest restaurants
in the history of America, certainly.
And you know,
I came up with a number that grant went,
there's no way the revenues that
high or they make that much money,
that's impossible. And it was really
funny because years later, um, you know,
I now work with, with
chef Keller, um, and he's,
he's a friend all these years later.
And I literally pulled that out one day
with grant being there and went like,
how close am I on this back
in 2005? And he's like, oh,
you're within like two or 3%. You know?
And, and grant was just like, and it's,
we're talking about back of the envelope
stuff. And so, you know, you asked like,
where can people start to
start a business? Start on
the back of an envelope.
Like one of my favorite exercises is to
sit in a restaurant or a small business
of some sort and just literally
do the back of the envelope.
That is the kind of calculation my
dad called it the two shoe box method.
Put me through college,
right?
Like money coming in and once you
bucks money going out and the other,
whatever's left is profit, you know,
um, you know, start that basic.
And,
and we did that and I didn't
really think about the,
we did well, but we didn't
make a ton of money. Um,
Alinea cost of two point
$2 million to build, um,
I up a little over a quarter of that
myself and found investors for the rest,
all of whom I knew. And, um, you know,
in the first year we did,
you know,
we made about 450 to $500,000
on four or $5 million in sales.
I'm not a great return, not a
terrible return. Um, we then one,
you know,
best restaurant in America from Gourmet
magazine and I was horrified that we won
that frankly. Um, I remember
Greg called me and said, Yep,
I just got a call from Ruth Reichle.
And like we had some stated goals of like,
how would we know if this is a success?
And one of the things we wrote down was
Ruth Reichl declares it best restaurant
in America.
And we wrote that because in 1997,
she wrote the most exciting place to
eat in America as the French laundry and
grant was there and cook that meal and
said that the energy of having someone
that he respected so much,
because Ruth is just a great writer.
She's one of the unimpeachable food
critics in the history of America.
And having her write that in New York
Times propelled that restaurant to its
permanent status. Um, I think
that can't happen nowadays,
honestly for other reasons, but
this is kind of pre, pre, you know,
Internet for Yelp,
all that.
And then all of a sudden we got that
and I was like horrified because,
you know, one of the goals was
completed so early we would have,
we wouldn't have our, like our
Lodestar, you know, and so, um,
he was like, Dear God, can you
let me enjoy it for like a minute
to you? Yeah. All right. You know,
I was happy, but I was also
like, oh no, now what do we do?
We need to find another artificial
constructs here. Like go after
enough of this, I need to find
happiness and get this other happiness.
I that in head out of my face.
So it's about,
I really do believe that actually,
that it's often the process is so real or
wording that when you get something done,
it can be a letdown, you know? And, um,
I wanted that process to go.
And then unfortunately,
six months later at grant was diagnosed
with stage four cancer and given six
months to live. Um, and so weirdly,
that was the moment where after he was
going through treatment where I started
going into the restaurant at night,
cause remember I'm not
a service professional,
I was running the business
of the restaurant. Um,
I would start going in at night and
asking really dumb questions again.
And you know, weirdly, um,
our goal was to keep Alinea open
for when he came back and my do,
he only missed like, you know, 12 days,
14 days of service during really
intense chemo and radiation and,
but he was given six months to live.
And you know,
when people are in that situation
and their livelihood is tied to this
restaurant,
um,
even despite their loyalties,
oftentimes they just need to find
another job because they were like, hey,
in four months,
this place is going to be closed.
So it was in, in, in the midst of that,
we decided to do our first book,
really, Dick Chronicle. Um, you know,
his, his, you know,
what he had accomplished because for
him he felt like that'd be his legacy.
Um, he thought he was going to die.
He was told he was going to die.
So in the midst of managing a
self created self published book,
um,
and trying to do that differently and
then keeping a dwindling staff motivated,
I'm trying to let him know that it
would still be there when he got, well,
all of that I started going, this
place is run in strange ways, man,
this industry is, is, is
not run right. You know,
and I started asking like basic questions,
like if we have a waitlist for a
hundred people on a, on a Wednesday,
why do we do 74 people on a
Wednesday but 86 on a Saturday?
And the answer was, because our
incentives are misaligned, you know,
the service industry as a whole can't
run it 100% every single day of the week
and less they're incentivized to do
so. And you could go like, well yeah,
but every server there will make an
extra hundred bucks a night or whatever.
But they're kind of going like, look,
if every night was Saturday I'd be dead.
It's really hard work,
you know?
So you need to figure out ways
of load balancing that, um,
and making every day the same
and you end up way ahead.
So from a business perspective,
um,
that's when my sort of self education,
uh,
in this industry came,
came forward and it came forward in a
way that I think I was less patient with
everything because we were also going
through this really difficult emotional
time.
Um,
and so consequently when I didn't
get answers that made any sense,
instead of being diplomatic about it, I
would just be like, well that's stupid,
you know,
and it was,
which cut some of the normal social filter
off and I'm sure it wasn't a pleasant
time to be around anybody.
But I also think it was accepted within
that environment at that time because
everyone knew what we were going through.
And so when we,
you know, years, years later when we
finally like, we're kind of like, hey,
we've got some ideas to build next.
And the Aviary,
that's when I kind of went like,
well,
we're going to do things
totally differently here. And
anyone who's not on board,
even though they work for us, like if
you're not on board all the way in,
like on getting rid of normal reservations
on not using telephones on doing all
these things, I'm like, you know, you
just, we don't have a place for you here.
Um, and man, it really worked. You
know, that was the basis of, you know,
I talked to every software company in
the industry asking for their API and is
asking to build essentially what's
options pricing software on top of
reservation and open table told me no.
And the pos systems told me no. Um,
I called theaters and went like,
what ticketing system do
you use? [inaudible] and all
those told me no. And um,
so I heard a single programmer,
um,
and he and I in six weeks built a
really rudimentary booking system,
but the first day we turned it on
and we sold $562,000 of tickets to a
restaurant for the first time. First time
ever. Okay. So pause here for a second.
No, no, no. This is great. This is great.
So a few a few things for folks
who are not familiar. Api,
APP application programming interface.
It's how you can effectively link
into someone else's software.
Pos point of sale, not piece of
shit. And it is a piece of shit. Oh,
it may also be a piece of shit.
What was,
what were the design specs that you
were looking for? In other words,
before you get to the 500,000
plus gay at the snap of a fingers,
like what were you trying to fix
or what were you trying to create?
So I get a lot of grief for
this, for saying this, um,
in the industry and in the press,
but basically whenever you
make a restaurant reservation,
one of the two of you talking
is lying to each other.
If you think about it, nor their
industry form of entertainment, uh,
which dining out is a form of
entertainment. I know it's sustenance.
I know there's so much culture
embedded in it and all that,
but you could eat at home, right? Um,
no other form of entertainment.
You just call them up and say, Hey,
hold a seat to the bears game or the
cubs game or the opera and I'll show up
around seven 30 and then
they tell you, yeah, yeah,
we'll have a seat ready for you at seven
30. And then when you get there, they go,
oh,
you know what,
go wait over there for 30 or 40 minutes
because we're running a little behind
tonight. You know? Um,
the reason that they're running behind
is because they overbooked because about
15 to 18% of the people just
don't show up. So they overbook.
They also know that if they tell you that
they'll really see you at nine and you
wanted an eight 15,
you'll just go to the restaurant down the
street from them that will lie to them.
Right? Right. So, so they,
so they do that and ultimately
it's just bad all around.
It's bad for the restaurant.
It's wasteful for food. Um,
and it's bad hospitality,
like, and that's like,
there are so many pop culture
references and entire Sitcom,
you know, episodes built around someone
trying to get into a restaurant. Right.
It's absurd. It's completely
absurd. And you know,
I looked at our no show rate at
Alinea datadriven tracked it.
I looked at our,
what we call short seated tables,
like the number of tables that were
four people, but only two showed up.
And the dirty secret there
is like people would go like,
well what do you have available a while?
I have an eight 30 for four okay,
we'll take that. And they never
intended to bring the other two people.
Well that's just as bad as a to tap Shawn,
we only have 74 people in there and
so it's a yield manager or 74 seats.
So it's a yield management problem.
And so we,
five to 8% of our revenue every night
was was being lost to that transaction.
That was a non transaction.
Right.
And so I wanted to figure out
ways to do two things. One,
what to figure out ways to make
it transactional. Because again,
you asked about Professor Thaler,
one of the key tenants is as a little
bit of skin in the game, right?
When people have small vested interest in
something and the outcome of something.
Or even if I gave you a pencil as a
gift and then 30 minutes later I want to
take it back, you will get so mad even
though you didn't care about that pencil.
Right, right. Cause you're like,
what was, that dude gave me a gift.
Now he's pulling it back and you know,
it's like the expected,
it's like the expected value of a mug.
If you ask them how much they would spend
to buy the mug versus giving them the
Mug and saying, how much will you accept
to sell it? You know the differential.
Yes. Huge. So you know, that
came to me one day because my,
my kids wanted to go see a movie at
night that I did not want to go see.
And I was really,
really like I would have easily paid 50
bucks to not go to this movie. Right?
Yeah. And then my wife basically says,
Hey, well let's go to that movie.
So I go on Fandango, I buy four
tickets, 60 bucks, whatever it was,
and it like five 30 at night.
It's pouring rain and everyone's
napping and they're like, yeah,
I don't want to go. And I'm
like, get your asses in the car.
We're going to the movie man, easily
paid that $60 to not go to the movie.
But once I had the sunk cost of,
of paying for the movie,
my psychology totally flipped.
And I was like,
we're going to this movie that
I don't want to go to like,
and I literally irrationally made
everyone go to the movie. Like,
which weirdly costs, you know,
I mean, from an emotional
family standpoint, all bad,
all the way around. Right. And um, so I,
I thought about it and I was like, wow,
what if people,
what do people put down a small deposit
on times when demand exceeds supply?
Like, right. So Saturday night,
eight o'clock, great. That's uh,
that's the best seats at the Opera House.
Let's see if people will prepaid for
that or put down 20 bucks for it.
That's fully credited at the end of
their meal. It's not a cover charge.
I'm not trying to squeeze people
in the actual cost of the meal.
I'm just trying to go like, yeah, let's
see if people will make a commitment.
And everybody told me, no,
no one's going to do that.
Like this is not the way it works.
But if you look back historically,
and this is the interesting part again,
it's about like digging in
deep on something and if
you look back historically,
um,
restaurant reservations started with the
telephone and at the time that we were
starting to do this,
the telephone was dying.
And I didn't know that at the time,
you know, it was eight years ago,
but I have a computer in my pocket and
if you ring me and I don't know your
number, I don't want to talk
to you, I don't answer it.
I'd much rather receive
like a little piece
of text letting me know what's going on.
Then a phone call.
Um,
similarly like calling a restaurant is
an antiquated thing to do at this point.
But long before the telephone people got
room and board and what room and board
was literally,
it was like you go to an inn and you,
you get a room for the night
and then do you need food? Okay,
well you got a board of food that was
literally it and you'd prepay for it.
And so,
you know,
there was hundreds of years of that long
before there was a telephone and people
called and said, Yep, like, you know,
I'd like to eat at your restaurant. Sure,
we'll let you know.
And um,
and so as the technology for
the telephone has morphed into,
you know, what we all have
in our pockets now, um,
I just wanted to update
that whole transaction.
And so I also wanted to acknowledge
that Tuesday nights it should be cheaper
than a Saturday night.
So it has to work in both ways.
I always thought Uber could to fix their,
their surge pricing issues
by having discounted pricing
when there was no demand,
like just move pricing in two directions.
And if you have pricing in two directions,
then like that whole argument
goes away. Right. Um, and so,
so we did that. We, we,
we priced out different prices by
day of the week and times a day.
So 5:00 PM on Wednesday at Alinea is still
cheaper than 8:00 PM on a Saturday by
a lot, by 80 to a hundred
dollars a person. Wow. Um, and,
and you know, what happens, um,
and this is now we have, you know,
hundreds of restaurants doing this
on our software called talk. Um,
what happens is people buy
the most expensive seats
first and the cheapest seats
first, which is exactly what
you'd expect actually, right?
Because there's some people who are
price conscious and go like, wow,
this is a really expensive meal,
but holy cow,
I don't really care if I eat at
five o'clock on a Tuesday. Great.
Like I can save 400 bucks. Um, and
then there's some people that go like,
I only eat at 8:00 PM on Saturday. Well,
okay, that's fine. Pay a little more.
Or they're attracted to the fact
that it is the most expensive. Sure.
That happens too. And then
there's, there's a whole bunch
of tools. Then over time,
we built on top of that to sell wine
pairings or sell books. You know,
we sell 20 Alinea books a day on
checkout with the booking process.
That's all ton because we're not going
to exit through the gift shop at Alinea.
It's a Michelin Three Star restaurant.
So we would suddenly have like one book,
like near the restrooms
that people could peruse,
but it didn't say like by the
book or anything like that.
So typically we'd sell like
one or two per night. Um,
now on checkout, when you
book Alinea, it says, hey,
would you like to buy and Alinea book
personalized and 20 people a night get it
at that has $400,000 in revenue a year.
Yeah. That's incredible. Easy. Right?
And it's amazing to me that no one did
that beforehand because ultimately people
can't buy what they don't see and people
don't want to be upsold inside of a
restaurant. There's nothing
worse in my mind then, you know,
some places that today's special is
today's special and it's real and you,
you kind of know that,
but sometimes it's just the old fish,
right? Uh, Sunday night
and we all know these things.
And like,
I think no restaurant wants to like raise
their hand to go, Yep, that's all true.
We were aligned to our customers and
we're not going to release it you at eight
15. And so I think when I said that, like
you can look back through some articles,
um,
I remember that there's an article,
I think it was in Gq that they
interviewed like a grizzled veteran,
you know, and he didn't use his
name and said, you know, um,
overbook in a bar to weight
and has always worked for me.
And I was just like,
how does that not sound like terrible
hospitality to everyone reading that,
you know? Yeah, for sure.
Yeah. Yeah. There's,
there's so many systems that have a
similar overbooking load balancing issues,
right? You'd look at airlines, you
look at hospitality. Yep. Eat dentist.
Yeah. I have a great dentist. They
only do it via phone call or email.
And so I have to play a guessing game.
It's like going into a clothing
store and going like, yeah,
I'm looking for a blue v-neck
cashmere sweater. Like, Nah,
don't have one guest again,
put the shit on display man.
Like,
just tell me what days
you could clean my teeth,
show me and I'll just go online
and hit the button, you know?
So when you then debuted the,
uh, the, the ticketing
option, if I'm, if I'm,
if I'm labeling it properly,
how did you prime the pump for that?
Was there anything, did you need
to prime the pump to have this,
what seems like certainly
a windfall? Yeah, we did a,
a, a, a video where, you know,
next restaurant was about a restaurant
that's always knew essentially like
what's, what's one of the big problems
of the restaurant industry? Well,
when you open a new restaurant,
it doesn't matter what it is,
people are gonna show up for like five
or six months. And then after that,
um, you know, you got to struggle to
like get regulars and, and you know,
like find new audiences and all of that.
But people like the new quote unquote.
Right. Um, the other problem is,
is that our own staff in chefs where the
kind of people who I said to grant one
time,
he cooked this amazing French dish for me.
It'll neo right in the middle of his
sickness because I had driven down from
Michigan, I've never eaten before
or after in the Alinea kitchen,
but he whipped up this little French
dish for me of duck. And I was like, man,
let's open a French restaurant
some day. And he went like, ah,
we'll get bored after six
months. And then I was at, um,
one of our chefs homes on a
day off Tuesday and he made,
he loves Thai food and he made
this amazing Thai meal. Amazing.
And I like, wow, like I had no idea.
These guys are so versatile, you know?
And then it made sense, hey, these are
passionate, amazingly talented people.
And it kind of dawned on me like,
let's just change the restaurant every
four months, you know, let's, let's do,
and then we dwelled on that for like
a year thinking like it was kind of
impossible to do. And then
you know, grandson, I said,
well let's start with the French menu.
And he's like, well what does that mean?
Like there's southern France,
there's lower valley, there's France,
that's the nouvelle cuisine. And then
there's friends from like, you know,
a hundred years ago. Totally
different. And I was like, Yup,
Paris 1906 I don't need to explain to
you what that is you'd want to eat that.
If I just said like if someone said, Hey,
new restaurant opening, what's the menu?
It's Paris 1906 I'd go like,
cool.
Like I want to do a little time
travel and see what that was like.
And so as soon as we had
like a city in a time,
we instantly knew that was the idea
that kept us up at night. You know,
where we went, like, wow,
look at all these different places we
can travel and what does that restaurant
look like and how do you create a kitchen
versatile enough to make all these
different cuisines and how do you make
it not feel like Disneyland where one
time you have a theme of Paris and
next time you have a theme of Japan.
So you have to go for like an austere
minimalism, you know. And um, is this,
what's usually the reason why you
chose the year 1906, you know,
I'm doing some research. Um, uh,
and I may get the exact date wrong
cause this is eight years ago I did the
research,
but I believe the sen flooded in 1908,
somewhere around there. Um,
and so, um, a scuff ea, um,
like the father of French
cuisine, um, was at the Ritz then.
And that was kind of like the
height of that era of cuisine.
And then after the sen flooded,
that's where you got sort of your bras
reason bistros because they had to kind
of go to a more casual,
it opened up for more people.
Took the price point down,
it made it more approachable and it wiped
out dozens of these fancy restaurants.
And so like rent got cheap
and all of a sudden like, hey,
like we're gonna get this new style of
restaurant that's roughly, as I recall it,
somebody's going to listen to this
and tell me I'm all wrong. But um,
that's where we landed because we
could do this a scuff ea menu and boy,
we argued about that too,
like in their blenders then so,
so like electric blenders.
So I mean we just like,
so you wanted to mimic the
production? Well, I did.
Grant did not so, so, so we, we, we were,
I remember we were at a, we invited
the press to a practice and it's like,
Hey pal, you don't have to
make the food. He was like,
should we make it intentionally
worse than we can? Yeah.
I guess the recipes were really vague.
They didn't even call for salt. Yeah. So,
so in the middle of this press dinner
where we had like the New York Times that
we had all sorts of these people there,
which I will never do again. Right.
That was just a genuine error.
Like and like,
like we were still arguing
out conceptually what this
thing would be and then we
serve dinner and we were like openly,
like he'd come out of the kitchen and we
would openly argue about it, you know?
And this is at the press
dinner? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember he brought the soup out and
it was like, you know, he was like,
I was like, oh they must have used
like the actual blenders, right,
like modern blenders. Cause it was like
the mouth feel is like perfect. Right.
And so I was like, oh you, you use the
blenders, you know? And he was like,
the recipe didn't call for salt
either did it, but I should,
I have not used that and had it
tastes like shit. And then I was like,
well maybe you don't know that they
didn't have refrigeration then either.
And they packed the vegetables
insult as a desiccant.
And so there were almost all pretty
self did by the time they get to Paris.
And that was it. Like people were just
like, these guys don't like each other.
But that was, that was, that's our method.
That's what we did, you know. And um,
I mean to the day we opened, we
had those, those arguments. Um,
and then, you know, in terms
of the software, like, man,
like I didn't sleep for a week.
Um, we set it up on Rackspace.
It didn't work right. I had never done
anything like that before. Um, you know,
it was like no one would help,
I think. Like, like, you know,
nobody would help no one. We,
and I say nobody would help.
You mean competitors potential. Uh, I
don't even know to tell potential. Like,
these are people, I got
it. Why wouldn't they help?
Don't, you know, like in the case
of open table, they had a monopoly.
So why, what makes sense to me? That
makes sense. In terms of everyone else,
I think they didn't just didn't get it,
but even people within my
own company thought this was
a fool's errand. You know,
like grant for sure.
Like he will fully admit this now.
I thought it was a terrible idea.
Why did he think it was a terrible idea?
Because it's not hospitable, it's not
hospitality. It's not, it's not, it's not.
It's low touch, high
touch. Correct. And, and,
and hugely the case where, you know, I'll,
I'll send the price is different every
day. Like are people going to get that?
And I just kept looking to
other industries and I'm like,
no one has a problem with it.
When they go to a baseball game then
they're not sitting on the, uh, you know,
above the dugout.
And then like the guy who's in the third
deck back row looks down and go, oh,
that guy. Like he totally
stole that ticket from me.
Two different price points,
you know?
And I just feel like people inherently
get that without having to explain it to
them. How, if I, if I may.
How far in advance of the opening
where you were you hoping to launch the
software and when did you end
up launching the software? Yeah,
I launched it about seven hours
before the first dinner. Holy Shit.
Um, I hope to have done it four
to five weeks ahead of that.
It was literally one
man operation plus me,
like one programmer and me.
Um,
when we launched it, um,
Rackspace, this is 2010.
I'm not saying anything about,
about Rackspace. It was, I didn't,
I probably set it up. We're on a 2010, um,
it did not like it's supposed to auto
load correct. And self propagate.
And it neither happened.
I was expecting we had 17,000 people on
our email list that it's signed up on
the website to like be notified when
when their bookings went on sale.
And I was expecting maybe,
you know, 700 show up,
like it should be fine.
And something like eight or 9,000 showed
up and everyone just kept hitting the
refresh key. And he has another
fatal error, um, of stupidity.
And this is not the way our software is
built now because we have professionals
here. But, uh,
basically my admin login
was on the very same server.
Everybody's public access God.
So I couldn't even go into configure it,
you know.
So the good news is that I couldn't answer
like hundreds of angry emails all at
once. So I created a Facebook group
for the business, which in 2010,
not very many people did.
And so if you go back and screw all
the way down to the beginning of that,
you'll see me going like, hey, if
everyone could please stop refreshing,
I can sort this out.
And what was really cool is that
people felt part of something. Um,
they felt like, wow, holy shit, this
guy is actually doing this himself. Um,
we're part of this experiment. Um,
and we're on the inside of it. Um,
I got a lot of empathy from the customers
even though they were the ones that
were unable to get what they wanted.
And then when it finally started working,
I mean,
I literally not showered in five days.
I had pizza boxes linear and it
looked like a bad movie startup thing.
I had a beard, like I was, you
know, just strung out manic.
And I remember I called grant and
it was opening day and he said,
how many should I prep for? And I
said prep for full, like cause if not,
we'll turn on the phones.
But I didn't tell him was that I didn't
order the phones cause I didn't want to
have a fail safe. You'd burn the ships. I,
yeah, I, I would, I just wanted to
make sure I, I forced myself to work.
So we had no phone line.
And um,
I it, when it started working,
I would double click, you
know, one of the functions,
it was like a double click on a table.
And if it was yellow,
it was held,
the public can see it.
I can make it available up by double
clicking it, who would turn green.
And then when it was sold, it would turn
red. But the first time I did that, um,
to act, to let more inventory out,
um, and clearly things were working.
It turned red so fast.
I thought it was broken.
And so then I went into the credit
card processing and saw, oh my gosh,
someone bought that that fast.
And I called grant, I said, dude,
you got to come to my
house. And he was like, uh,
we're opening a restaurant and like
six hours, what's going on? I said,
as the guy who helped save your life,
getting a fucking taxi,
you can come over here cause I
need to show you something. And
he looked at me and kind of went like,
what is wrong with you? Right. And,
and I took him upstairs to my office and
I said, I explained what I just to him,
I just explained to you and I said,
click on one of those, make it available.
And he said, which one? I
go, anyone in the next month.
And he clicked like three weeks out at
nine 30 and it instantly turned red and
another window I had the credit
card thing up and I go, look,
Mr. Jones bought that. And he
went, really? And I'm like,
Yep, there are, you know, 4,000 people
waiting for you to do that right now.
And that was the moment at which I,
I was basically like,
this is the best thing I've ever built.
Because,
because it was, it was, it was,
it was functionally different than
any way that anybody was doing this.
It wasn't novel. It was just
applied in a novel way. And so,
you know, what was interesting is that
of course the software itself sucked,
but as a proof of concept, it was
awesome. Quick question on that.
If you're comfortable answering how much,
how much money had you put into
developing the software at that point?
Roughly, I'm going to
say $115,000. Yeah. Okay.
In your mind, were you completely
confident it would work or, and there's,
it doesn't have to be a or B.
There can be CDF or where you,
like you don't have 415 k
or whatever it might be.
Even if you budgeted for
less than it overran the,
even if there is a 20% chance that this
works is it is worth risking the hours
and time because it will so completely
transformed what we're doing and if it
fucking fails, who cares? Correct.
Yeah, the latter one. Yeah. Again,
it's about the asymmetric risk.
Right?
And it was also about this thing and
that as I dug into how Alinea ran,
there's like things that you can fix and
control and there's things you can't.
Right. And this was the one that,
you know, I would answer phones,
it'll linea. And I would, it
was like being a therapist.
People would go like, I
would like to, you know,
make a reservation on my anniversary,
you know,
seven weeks from now on a Thursday, and
you're like, I'm really sorry. Start.
It's totally full. And 100% of time they
thought you were lying to them. And,
and,
and so consequently I realized that we
were saying no to people more than we
were saying yes.
And that even when we said no in a
nice way and took 10 minutes to do so,
um,
people thought that we were lying or that
they weren't important to us or any of
those things.
And so I felt that transparency was
actually more important than the actual
money. And at the actual
yield management, I felt like,
like allowing people to see the entirety
of the inventory was the most important
thing.
And I had this re like same
thing with like, you know,
the trading markets. Um, they've moved to
more and more and more transparency, um,
more and more speed. This is true across
every industry. And I just felt like,
wow, this industry I found
myself in was so backwards.
And so I just wanted to make the
whole thing more transparent.
And so even if it didn't go
beyond my own restaurants,
I was totally fine with that.
In fact,
I didn't do anything with
it for four years. Um,
and I didn't really intend on
making it like a software product.
I intended on fixing my own problems.
And I think often that's where,
that's where good ideas come
from. Oh, super often. Yeah.
The scratching of your own
edge, at least, you know,
you have a market of one guy's
guaranteed market of one.
And I also want to point out when we're
talking about asymmetric risk earlier
and you're like,
well,
I want to stand to make three
to four x what I stand to lose.
And if you run the math, and I'm sure
I'm missing a lot of subtleties here,
but when you said we booked 500 x thousand
dollars and it cost 115 we're getting
very much within the ballpark of that.
But I didn't even like, I mean, well,
I mean since then it's like we've taken
our margins at our restaurants from 10
to 12% to, you know, at times
in good month, 20 to 25%.
I'm in an industry that
over the last five years,
if you read,
I give a talk called Tuesday's not
Saturday and seven things you already know
but are doing nothing about.
Um,
it's a talk that I give to the
restaurant industry. And, you know,
one of the things that,
that I point out in there is that,
you know,
there's so many obvious things that
you could be doing to improve your
hospitality,
to improve your booking process,
to get rid of food waste.
Um,
but people tend to just kind of move
along because it's a really chaotic
environment. It's hard to make change
in it because every day is game day.
Like you wake up every day and a hundred
people are going to come through the
door and if your
fishmonger doesn't show up,
all you need to figure out what to
do with that, you know? And so it's,
it's not really about the return on
that one investment at that one moment.
It's more like, you know, a thousand
small improvements over time.
And you know,
what,
if I look back at that system that I built
then compared to what we have now, um,
you know, it's a minuscule part
of what it turned into. Um,
but it was the seed of an idea,
which is more important, which is,
hey, let's, let's shake
things up. And then I,
I got a great CFO who was
at Bain consulting and he,
he came on to like help manage the
building of the project of next. Um,
and when he started wanting to build
out a business team, I was like, great,
like run with it.
And so we've built out food cost
analysis that uses Marimekko charts.
It's totally different because it's
visual and you give that to the chef uses
what shirts. Ah, Marimekko uh, if you,
if you don't know Marimekko if
you get nothing out of this,
one of the greatest visualizations,
um, in, in charts that
you could like, you know,
do an excel or whatever,
um, hard to do vocally. Um,
but imagine a square where each,
um,
of your x axis is the percentage
of let's say food costs.
And then, um, each square within
there is like, I don't know,
meat or produce,
but the whole of the square is 100%.
The y access is 100% of one metric
and the x axis is 100% of another.
So you could kind of look at any given
square and see how much that impacts the
whole, it becomes like a big lego
building with different colors.
Um,
if you give a busy chef
400 receipts and say, Hey,
every Friday looked through
all these and you know,
figure out what we're spending
too much on or worse, Hey,
your food costs last month for
36%, I need him at 32%. Um,
you can't take percentages to the bank.
Let's talk about dollars.
Let's see where we can say some
dollars. Um, or the revenue.
You could have just gone down
that month for whatever reasons,
August in New York. And so as, it's
not really a good way to look at it,
but you give this
person, this, this chart,
this mere Meco know Marimekko his name,
m a r I m e k k o chart. Is
that right? Again, not good.
I think so there is a Google result,
which is how to make a
Marimekko chart in excel.
So I'm guessing that's probably it.
There's medicine, youtube videos as well.
So I'll, I'll put this in the show notes
for people. Man, I got to tell you,
like from a utility perspective,
you show that to a person, you explain
it visually, like when you see it,
it makes much more sense.
And they instantly get it and they
look at it and they're like, oh,
there's no way I spent that much on facial
last month. You know, and this can be,
this can be used for things outside. Okay.
Everything. Yeah. It's not just food,
not just restaurants.
Oh, no, no, no. It's,
it's just a great visualization
of utility and they're like,
consultants love it. And I got to tell
you, I don't love consultants in general,
but, but, but if I've
learned anything from,
from the best consultant
that I've ever hired,
like who is now my partner
and CFO, um, he, you know,
he came up with this and as
soon as I saw it, I was like,
how did this not enter my life until
my 40th year? This makes no sense.
You know? Um, it's just incredibly
useful. But my point is, is that we,
we kind of went through everything in
the restaurant and went like, well,
what are the biggest spending areas
that we can like analyze? And, um,
it's true in any endeavor
that you're doing, you know,
there's no point in looking at,
at the dimes if you've got something
that costs $1,000, start there. So,
um, you know, and that's, you know,
getting into like our thoughts
on our publicity or PR.
Like we don't have a professional PR
person and haven't in 14 and a half years.
Um,
we,
we don't spend money on any
promotions other than social media.
Um, and then with the social media,
we track all of that, you know, um,
we can see what our Roi
is on a boosted post. Um,
we can see what our ROI is if we
advertise on your podcast. And you know,
those are, that's, that's why
these mediums are working,
um, is because there are
measurable, you know, I,
I was looking up just as you were
chatting and as I was also looking for a
Marimekko,
a quote that I think applies and you
may certainly feel free to disagree but
applies very well to a lot
of the breakthroughs that,
that you have experienced and also help
to catalyze in a lot of what you've
done. And it's quote from Charlie
Munger who for those who don't know,
you should definitely take a look at
poor Charlie's Almanack. He's the,
the the right hand or I shouldn't even
say that he is the investing partner of
Warren Buffet and a fascinating,
fascinating human being. But one of,
one of the quotes of his that I really
returned to a lot when I think I might be
outsmarting myself in some way, uh,
or in general as a reminder is quote,
it is remarkable how much long term
advantage people like us have gotten by
trying to be consistently not stupid
instead of trying to be very intelligent.
Yeah. Because you, you've,
as you noted earlier,
you have these practices that are
being implemented by otherwise,
in many cases, smart people who've
just not taken the time to ask,
why are we doing this? Why does
this exist as a thing? Why would,
why does, like you pointed out, it's so
obvious once you reframe it,
like you walk into a clothing
store and they're like, okay,
what are you looking for him? Nope.
Sorry, it gets again. It's like,
that's fucking ridiculous.
Right?
And yet that's exactly the way it
works in many other places. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's it.
Once you start down that
road of thinking that way,
it will drive you a little
nutty because you stuck.
Like you can't do every business,
you know? And um, you know,
there's a couple things that I've got
my back pocket that I'm kind of like,
you know,
one day I'm going to arbitrage truffles
because it's like there's an opaque
market that's absurd. Like, you know,
it's like there, here's an example,
I'm gonna give somebody out there,
call me up because this is
a real business idea. Um,
and I've been wanting to do it for years,
but you know, black and white truffles,
not the kind,
not the chocolate ones,
but the kind that the dogs dig up in
France and Italy are as expensive as the
most expensive drugs in the world.
Um,
you order them is if it were an illegal
drug, of course they're perfectly legal,
but you call it a truffle dealer.
Um, and you go like, you know,
what do they cost while they're,
you know,
650 a pound right now for black truffles,
16 for White.
You'd try to talk them down a little bit.
You make sure that you get
the best quality because hey,
we're Alinea and we will ship you back.
This stuff we don't like and all that.
And then in an unmarked box stacked
with newspaper will come $20,000 of
truffles. Good for like
a week by the way. Like,
not like this is not like a big supply
and is completely opaque as a market.
Um, there is no mycologists
touching these. Um,
there are knock offs from Minot,
not knock outs.
There's different species and quality
from Australia, from Tennessee, from,
from China, um, etc. Etc.
That they cut into it
so familiar. Um, and,
and like it was my, like we spend a
lot of money on truffles every year,
um,
and try to figure out what the u s market
in the fall truffle season is worth.
You can't, it's exactly like publishing.
You can't find numbers, you know,
and so whenever I, whenever I see
something like that, I'm like,
someone's guarding their, their
golden goose, you know, that whatever,
whenever it's a black box,
you're like,
I feel like I am not on the best side of
this trade. That's right. That's right.
And that's what I did.
Um, you know, I did, um,
a closing insular network between the
merch and the Amex to arbitrage ETFs to
get rid of the phone
brokers in the middle.
That took me like a year and a half
to get through the murk and Amex,
um, powers that be, um,
red, like most of the CFTC.
So when they would tell me it's not
like in the rules or not legal or notice
this CFTC Chicago trade, which is the, uh,
the federal commodities trading
commission. I see. Okay.
It's like the sec, but for commodities.
I gotcha. Um, and you know, again,
sit down and actually read that someday.
Like what's amazing is that the
experts and never, it's like,
it's like the members of Congress who
don't read the bill and then if you ask
them detailed instructions on it, they're
like, oh yeah, I don't really know,
but the general tenor is this or that.
Um,
the people who were governing the
exchanges had never read the rules,
so they would just quote to me, they
would just quote to me like, you're not,
it's against the rules.
And I'd be like, well,
here are the seven volumes police show
me where if not, I'm going to do it.
You know? Um, and so
similarly, like truffles,
same thing. Um, the, the, you know, the
booking for the restaurant, same thing.
Open table had a monopoly. They wouldn't
tell you who your customers were.
They would sell your customers. They
still do. To other restaurants. If you,
if you're full one night,
they'll just send you down the street to
a Japanese restaurant down the street.
They don't care.
So I wanted to get rid of all that.
So I built the software for that.
Truffles,
I will someday build a truffle exchange.
So question for you. This is, this is, uh,
this is something also for,
this is maybe just turning this into a
therapy session slash coaching sessions
for myself,
but I get attracted like a
moth to the flame to puzzles
and I've got a puzzle. No, no, no. I
don't need any more thoughts on this.
I need to do more puzzles.
But you, there are many,
many black boxes out there,
right? You have, you have
truffles. And like you said,
it's like,
all right,
what's the market size of the
truffle exchange at x point in time?
Don't know. Right? Uh,
although you guys, uh,
as one establishment or
multiple sessions by a lot,
there might be a hundred different
black boxes like that that you run into.
How do you choose the black boxes
worth trying to shine light on like a
detective? Because it's going to consume
energy, it's going to consume time.
How do you pick and
choose which to go after?
It's, it's, it's, it's
like the manic test, right?
Like it's like the one
that bothers me the most,
like I kind of start doing, you
know, um, and then, uh, you know,
and then it's iterative from there.
Like sometimes you find yourself in a
construction of your own doing that was
accidental. Like all
of a sudden, you know,
you kind of opened your mouth and said
something like the truffle thing and all
of a sudden like, well, okay, I guess
we're building the truffle exchange.
I feel like the boring company
is like that from us. Like, like,
like he opened his mouth and be
like, yeah, just big, big, you know,
dig big tunnels and he's got enough
credibility now where some engineer's went
like, yeah, we could build, you know,
we can dig tunnels that are seismically
fine and like, hey, you work for space X.
Okay. Like, let's see if you
can build a dig a tunnel.
I don't think that was like a
business plan, you know? And,
and he just has a lot of credibility.
Um, you know, at this point, um,
I think that to a certain extent,
like a lot of people have a lot of ideas,
they just don't dig down
that rabbit hole. And, um,
so, you know, I, I do
some as like a hobby. Um,
I do somewhere, I kind of have someone
that I like within our company and say,
well, if you really wanted to be
independent and do something cool, like,
here's a project, like learn more about
this and start researching it. You know,
we have,
you know,
300 and some employees on the restaurant
side and about 50 on talk. Um,
many of them are incredibly hardworking
and intelligent. And when someone says,
Hey, I want to learn how
to be more entrepreneurial,
I take one of my black boxes out and
say, well, let's see if that's true
because it's going to take you six
months of independent work without any
guidance and you're going to
get tired of it really fast.
Or we're going to come back to me
and say, Hey, you know what? Like,
I can't figure out the total value of
the truffle market in the United States.
And I'm like, yeah, no shit.
That's why I asked you to do it.
Now, would you give them an assignment
like this? Or like, you know what boss,
I really want to be an entrepreneur.
You're like, congratulations.
I'm now giving you a project and a,
it's on your time and you're
not getting paid for it.
Oh, no, no, no. It's not. No, no, no, no.
I, I never, never, never take every single
intern that works at our restaurants
for a minute is paid. Gotcha.
So even if you get paid for the black
box time, oh yeah, of course. Yeah. Yeah.
I would never,
like,
I think one of the things that I
really dislike actually our industries,
like where they say, hey, like you're,
you know, you're in college or whatever,
you know, be an intern and then,
you know, your parents say, yeah,
that's a great opportunity for you
to learn something and all that.
And it's like, well, you're probably
not, if you're not getting paid,
you're not being valued,
frankly. And, um, for me, I, we,
we pay everybody. Like I don't
nobody who's working here. Um,
I, I do expect that, you know,
salaried people are going to work
more than just the time here.
And I think that people who
are passionately curious
will be given a problem
like that and we'll come up
with interesting solutions
to finding out what the
answer may be and that that's enough.
You know.
So I want to add some sort of
commentary on the question that I asked,
which is a,
I think it's incredible that you do
pay them for that independent research,
which is also acting as entrepreneurial
training slash filtering for them.
Uh, but I wouldn't have judged
too harshly at all if you said no,
that's on their own time.
And the reason I say that is that if
you are going to be investigating black
boxes as an entrepreneur,
there are going to be periods of time
where you are doing it in the evenings.
You were doing it on the weekends.
You are doing it without a clear
road to immediate cash flow. Right.
So I wouldn't have judged you if you said,
you know what,
I am paying them full
time for their normal job,
but if they want to tackle
one of these black boxes,
that's considered extracurricular time.
Uh,
so I wouldn't have judged too harshly
if you had respond in the, uh,
in the negative on that. Yeah. I
mean, I guess, I guess, you know, to,
to back up a little bit, like when
there are people who I don't know,
who do not work for our company,
and they called me up and say, Hey,
I've got this idea for x, y, Z or
whatever. And it's intriguing enough,
I will,
I will pose some more difficult questions,
but they're not working for me.
You know what I mean? Like there's,
there's a guy who brought me a
food product that I, you know, uh,
about a year ago and it was
interesting but not super compelling.
And I said, hey, if you
did these five things,
it would be a lot more compelling for me
to be involved and to help with it and
all of that.
And yesterday I got a box in the mail and
he had done not only the five things I
said, but said, hey, when I started doing
those, these seven other things popped up.
Here's where the product is,
here's the people we signed,
here's the airline we just
signed to carry the product.
And I would love to
have you still involved,
even though we're so much farther down
the road than I thought it'd be a year
later. That's super cool.
Like, Hey, that guy obviously,
but there's a person who's
truly entrepreneurial, right?
And did this on his own time.
Um, but if they're working here,
if they worked for the ALINEA group, if
they work for talk, like for sure there,
you know, you could take time during your
day, like doing your normal business.
That's a project that we're
working on. And, um, you know, we,
we also try not to have such harshly
defined rules and that within the
restaurant, like, look, if you're
a server, if you're a captain,
if you're a aligned cook,
um, you're probably not
working on my truffle project.
I mean realistically, you know, that's
not, but on the business side, um,
we certainly have, um, people
who, who work in roles, um,
as like a lawyer or an
analyst or something like
that who want to get involved
with our publishing project or who want
to get involved with the truffle project
or whatever it may be.
And you know,
I'm happy to pull them in and try to
include them. And you know, like you said,
you used the word as an
entrepreneurial filter. Um,
I would say 95% of the time people
filter themselves up. Right?
Yeah, I agree with that. I mean, they're
going to sell self, select your self,
select out. Yeah. Uh,
are there any particular
books or resources that you've
found useful on a hiring
or managing God if you found one?
Let me know.
Now. Hiring is so hard. I think it's
the hardest of all things to do.
Um,
and I think my style of interviewing
people is totally different than it was 20
years ago.
Um,
we use the word self selecting just a
moment ago and it's exactly what I do.
I kind of bring people in,
I let them know what I'm about,
what the company's about.
They've probably already been
interviewed by other people before they,
they get to me.
And so at that point I let them know like
what are the upsides and downsides of
working here, you know, and I kind of
let them know what the expectations are.
And I,
I tell them like,
people self select into a job and you
don't want to come here if you're going to
fail because that would be terrible and
I don't want you to come here and fail
because that would be a waste of my time
and resources and would also feel awful.
It's never good to like go if
someone feels terrible. So let's see.
If you are self selecting in,
what do you want to know?
Like I'll be completely transparent
about what's good, what's bad,
what's good about working
for me personally,
the fact that you maybe you'll
never see me again. I mean this,
it's like a big enough organization where,
you know,
there are definitely people working here
who, who I don't know at all. Um, but
people tend to join organizations
where they want to work.
And so I tried to make that process.
I tried to make them be able to say
no easier than they can say yes.
What would be some examples
of how you do that? You know,
I kind of judge the person by
what they're pain points are.
And so if someone says like, you know,
one of the things like to ask, you know,
which it kind of resonates probably
with, with you as I say, hey,
we're less five books he read.
And I gotta tell you,
that's a really hard question to answer.
Um,
because even if you're a voracious reader,
it's really like,
you remember like a
book from two years ago,
but you can't remember the one you
read two months ago sometimes. Totally.
At least I can't,
you know.
And so that is a great filter on people
because a couple of things will happen.
One, the person who is a veracious reader
will go like, oh my God, I swear to God,
I read like 20 bucks this year. Um, let's
see. And then we'll really start going,
oh, well I read one like three months
ago that was this. And it was about that.
And you can tell that
they're intellectually
curious and, and read a lot.
Um, you'll also get a person who goes,
look, I haven't read a book in 20 years,
but every night I go home and I do
woodworking and that's my outlet.
That's where I focus,
that's my zen moment.
And that's a valid answer to
that question too. You know,
like you don't have to be a reader. Some
people will just lie through their teeth
and they'll, they'll answer
what they think is the smart
answer to that question.
And I don't want that person there.
I read war and peace and then I went to
the problems of philosophy and uh, yes,
yes, yes. The four hour work week.
So definitely not the right answer.
So, so, um, so there's that and
I asked that kind of question,
but then like things like, do you
enjoy writing? Like, I like one of my,
like one of my things is like, if someone
doesn't like to write, what do we,
when people ask what I do for a living,
I say I'm a writer. And they go like, Oh,
you've written a couple books. And I go,
no, no, no. I read about 400 emails a day.
And that skill is hugely important right
now. If someone doesn't like to write,
they're not gonna want to
work for me because when,
when they send out an email and I cc'd
on it and it isn't a well thought out
little thing, the answer
coming back is like, hey,
here's four ways to improve this.
Um,
and at some point it will be like,
really,
you did that same mistake again?
Like it comes off kind of harsh and email,
you know?
Um,
and so if you're the kind of person that
doesn't take feedback well or doesn't
want to learn, like, man, I don't, I,
I'm lacking patients for that
at this point in my life. Um,
and I let them know that. And some people
like look at and you can just go like,
yeah dude, I don't want to work
there. Like more than I would think,
which is great.
You know,
simplifies matters and it's not, it's
not, it's done with a smile. You know,
I'm not like trying to like terrorize
people and they come in and interview and
then there's some people
that go like, awesome, that's
exactly what I want. And um,
you know, we've everything
from like, you know,
double phd engineers to um,
people who've never attended a
university for a minute and um,
but they've, they've self selected
into an organization that, um,
people ask a lot of questions.
I love that.
Like I can be in room and of the idea and
everyone there, I'll just be like, well,
that's a great idea.
There's no way we're going to be able to
do that next six months because that's
not,
that's not in our,
it's not in our capacity
at our size right now.
I think a question on a lot of people's
minds and a pain point for most people
listening will be email.
So you seem to be at least confident
in your treatment of email.
Uh,
400 is a lot of email.
Do you have any particular commandments,
do's do nots times you check
things you check first.
Any types of systems or approaches that
allow you to maintain a degree of sanity
with, with the amount of
email that you must receive?
You're going to hate this answer?
I am terrible at it.
Um, it used to be, uh,
not so long ago that I personally replied
to absolutely every single email that
came in myself and I used to have an
auto sign that basically it was like,
if I don't reply to you within
five minutes, I'm dead or asleep.
And it's the opposite of everything
that you stand for. I know that
I was listening to Jason, so Jason
Fried's a friend, I was listening to his,
his podcast with you.
And um,
I don't get it at all.
Like I am not,
I would love nothing
more than, um, you know,
it's a rework or to not
work, um, you know, you know,
work four day weeks or to
have six week projects.
And all of this stuff that he espouses.
Um, he's a friend, he's an investor in,
in one of my businesses.
Um, but man, I don't,
that's not how I function at all.
Um,
and I really think that he misses
cause and effect a little bit.
Like he has a very successful company
and that's the cause that allows the
effect, which is the ability to
manage your time really well. Um,
I live really paranoid,
I'm more comfortable that way.
And also I kind of feel like a
weird moral responsibility to,
um,
reply to the people who've taken their
time out of their day to write us a note,
you know, um, even if it's not
like critical business for me. Um,
and one of the things I did for about
10 years that I loved doing, uh,
when we first started linea,
is that I would have Google alerts set
up and I would find some blog, you know,
that only like some woman
in her mother red, you know,
and I would reply
personally, like say, wow,
thank you for the great
writeup for Millennia.
And there'd be kind of mind blown that
I found it and you know, all that. Um,
I treated email that way for
a long period of time. Um,
unfortunately now I can't quite do that,
so I do have a bunch of
filters and whatnot, but I
didn't even set them up. Um,
my business partner,
Brian Fitzpatrick,
who used to be the head of Google Chicago
and he's my, he runs the engineering,
he's the CTO of talk. He kinda said like,
dude, you're, you're slipping man. Like,
you know, you need to grate
some filters and, and,
and get some stuff that's directly to you.
So he went into my Gmail accounts and
kind of kind of forced the issue for me.
Um, but so now I can't quite do that. Um,
I do wake up in the morning and look at
sort of our, our bazillion social media,
um, uh, messages and whatnot. Kind of
pick a random one and just answer it.
Like,
I,
I want to be involved in knowing
what our customers are asking,
what they're doing, what they're
saying, what they're applying,
anything that's a complaint actually
gets brought directly via email to a
complaint tracker that me and grant see.
Um,
and so luckily there
are that many of those,
but anytime you serve five or 6,000 people
a week, you're going to get, you know,
some, something going wrong. Um, but
man, I'm terrible at it, honestly,
and I think I've tried,
I won't tell you a funny thing
is that when I go on vacation,
I do try to concoct a,
a,
a, a pretty funny, um, I
basically say like, look,
I'm going to be in a mountain or
on a boat or whatever and you're,
I'm not gonna be able to apply. Um, what?
And so I would make these
elaborate stories up almost
as like a fun piece of art
project as to why I couldn't do
it. And so one year, um, I, uh,
every year, every time I went
away, I would basically say like,
I'm going to visit a panda that I adopted
Chicago.
And it ended the year around Christmas
time when I went on break with a, with a,
with a,
a picture of a baby panda and a really
kind of mediocre Photoshop job of me
standing there
and attribute and called me up like
three days later going, you know,
is it going to the Lincoln Park Zoo? Like,
and I was like, no dear God, it's not.
And the following, there was
no panda. I look back though,
those might tell you reply to that. And
then the following year I said like, um,
I like to talk as you
might be able to tell.
And so everyone who knows me knows that
like I can just go on and on. Right.
And so I said,
I was going to a combination of a
tantric sex retreat and silence retreat
for eight days to explore my
both inner and outer self. And,
um, and you know, this is
your out of office reply.
That's my out of office replies and,
and, and anybody would get that.
Right.
And so I thought that was really funny.
And then about two years later,
I bumped into some guy who worked for a
very big corporation and they wanted to
do some work with,
with the one group,
and it was like kind of a
consulting project, very lucrative.
And he was looking at me really funny,
you know, and I said, like, what's up?
And he said, well, you know, I really
wish we had worked together, but you know,
then you went to that sex retreats.
I just couldn't get it past
everybody and I was just like,
I was looking at him going like,
what are you talking about?
And then I remembered like
four years earlier auto
out of office reply. And I told him
like, that it was kind of a joke,
like the panda and uh,
and he did not find any humor in it.
And I did. I thought it was hilarious,
even though we lost the business.
I thought it was really funny. Um,
so if you ever get a really
unusual out of office reply for me,
it's fiction probably. I love that. Uh,
I mean if you're serious all the time,
you're never going to get
the actual series work done.
You're going to burn out
before that ever happens.
I also want to underscore one thing and
then I want to ask you about a black box
at you and I have talked about quite
a bit, which is publishing. Uh,
the fact that you pick a message to
reply to even if it's one is really
important.
And I've noticed this certainly
with the audience that I have,
listeners, readers, et Cetera,
it is not physically possible
for me to reply to everyone.
It would also be anathema to everything
that I'm espousing a in many of the
books.
But I do want to,
I do want to demonstrate that I
am listening and I think that it,
it goes a really long way, even if
you do not personally reply to people,
if you are able to prove that you're
paying attention and that seems to resolve
a lot or at least act as a solve for
people out there who very seldom feel
heard, which does not always
necessitate a response.
So I just wanted to point out that it
might seem like a drop in the ocean,
but it actually has much further reaching
implications when you, when you do it,
what, what you were describing. I feel
like, um, it's genuine. First of all,
I'm always curious like what, what,
what are people writing about, um,
to the restaurants? What are
they writing about? To me? Um,
my linkedin profile basically,
like I don't really read Linkedin at all.
I keep it, I think it's
important to have it. Um,
but I don't ever read the messages on
there, but in my bio it basically says,
if you can find my email address, I will,
I will incite this, I will reply to you.
Um, and so that gets rid of all of
the marketing crap that comes in.
But every now and then I get like,
you know, a subject line, um,
to the email address that's on there
that says basically like, you know, hey,
via your linkedin bio, and
I'll, I'll read that and reply.
And it just shows me that like, hey,
there's an actual human on the other line.
It's not just a marketing
thing and be like, they really,
really do have something that they want
to talk about. Um, and so you know,
it's like little things like that are
kind of puzzle filters I guess that I call
them. Like where I just create like a
little bit of a little bit of a barrier.
And if you, um, if you're really into
it and you really want to talk to me,
you can pretty much find me pretty
easily. I'm not that hidden. Yeah,
the detail is really important here.
The mini hurdle. I have a friend,
I'm not going to mention by
name because get delusion, but
he is a very,
very successful author and journalist.
And when he is hiring for different
positions part time or full time at the
bottom of the job description on a
job site or wherever it might be in,
in small print,
at the very bottom it will say,
do not send a message on this platform.
Do not send an email,
even though email addresses given earlier,
call this number and leave a voicemail
answering the following things and
automatically he takes the pool of a
thousand people who are going to do the
wrong thing and finds the 10 people who
are actually paying attention. Yeah, 100%.
Uh, so publishing, what
is, I, we didn't really,
we didn't really talk much about it,
but can you give a little bit,
just a tiny bit of background on
the aviary and then some of your,
uh,
related publishing investigations,
which I think is, is not, I
think it's not a miss, uh,
in unappropriate word. Uh,
if, if you could give people
a little bit of of context.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm going to back up before the aviary
just a little bit and just go like,
you know, for a chef, doing a cookbook
is something that they dream about.
If there are serious chef from
the time they're 15, you know,
just like if you're a basketball player,
you want to make the NBA or you know,
if you're a runner, you're going to
want to be in the Olympics or whatever.
Like to grant,
um,
to a bunch of chefs having their own
ideas in a physical beautiful cookbook,
um, is kind of a holy grail
for them. It's very sacred.
And what was interesting is that,
um,
just before grant was sick,
we started getting a lot of publishing
offers and the natural inclination was to
go to what he knew, which
was artisan press, um,
which published at the French laundry
book, which is one of the bestselling, um,
high end cookbooks ever.
And it's certainly beautiful.
It was very revolutionary at its time.
Uh,
I think it was published in about
[inaudible] 98 [inaudible] 99,
something like that. And, um,
the typical publishing deal
like kind of came into us,
which was great that they were
coming in and it was, you know,
250 to $300,000.
And they would basically
say, well, out of that,
like you're going to pay for the designer
and the photographer and you need like
a 30 day photo shoot and you know,
here are the guidelines for how many
photos you want in the book and you know,
to keep costs down and this and that.
And I kind of looked at all of that and
all the offers came in within about 10%
of each other, which immediately, you
know, the hair on the back of my neck,
like the spidey sense,
spidey sense just telling me that
something back there is pricing this in an
unusual way. And then, um,
and then I started going
like, oh, this is actually,
you liked the music industry.
I knew people in,
in bands that would get signed to a record
label back in the day and they would
get a quarter million dollar advance.
You know,
shit that's seems like a lot of money,
right? And then all of a sudden,
all your studio time comes out of that
and you don't recoup another dime until
you've sold,
you know,
x number of records or cds or in
this case books. And then in the,
in the contract it actually said,
and the restaurant guarantees that they
will buy 2,500 bucks at half of retail
price. And I was like,
Whoa, that's, you know,
you're looking at something like $80,000
right there that goes right back to
them in essence. Like, and
then I kind of went like, well,
I wonder what a book costs to print.
And I mean, I just call it,
I asked them like, well,
how much does this book and the cost
of print? Well, I don't really know.
And so what they would do is that they
would always have layers of people so
that they said, well, that's not what I
do. Like I am the person that does this.
The lawyers give the contract, the
printer does the printing. Like I,
there's always plan a plausible
deniability or plausible ignorance.
Yes. Willful plausibly
ignorance. Yeah. Um, and,
and so I, I do what I started
doing. I'm like, well,
let's just Google that up and see what it
costs to print a book or hey, how many,
how many copies of the
French laundry books sold,
how many copies of 50 other books
that we wanted to emulate or that we,
that we thought were
well done sold. And, um,
man, it's like asking for like, you know,
keys to the Vatican or something when
you call a publisher and asked them that,
um, they, I'm sure you know this, right?
You probably know now because you've,
you've been so entrenched in the industry,
like you know your numbers and you
might know who the head of some of your
colleagues and friends, right? Um,
but if you want it to actually do a
meaningful comparison across the industry,
it's almost impossible to do it.
Even though that there is
a company that does that,
then you start trying to reverse engineer
it and you go to the New York Times,
which you can go to the New York Times
website and just look at how has the New
York Times, uh, you know,
bestseller list, um,
created and on their own site they say
it's a compendium of known publishers
like publishing houses as well as
these like top 50 retailers, you know,
back in the day. Um, and it's
a game mobile system, right?
Like the way that,
that the publisher publishers want to
do it is that they want to ship out all
the books at the same time because that's
how they're counted for the New York
Times bestseller list and stuff.
I should also know it's not only gainable,
but it's also conversely s highly
subjective within the New York Times.
So there, there's a lot of
wiggle room. In other words,
it is not like the Olympics.
We were like, okay, clear gold,
silver, bronze video replay. We
know exactly how this was, was, uh,
was it was
tabulated. Um, yeah. So the more
that we dug, the more that, um,
we got like Curie,
like more and more curious,
a little bit angry actually.
And,
but grant was weirdly angry at me
because he's going like, well dude, like,
why do you care? I, you know,
it's like I've been wanting this since
I was 15 and I was like, well, look,
if this is our budget, it's not
going to be the book you want this.
I can be as good as you want it to be
because we're not going to able to spend
six months doing the photography. We're
not going to be able to get great pages.
We're not gonna be able to get a
picture of every dish. Like if,
what do people cook in a cookbook while
they tend to cook those pages where they
see a picture of the final dish, because
you know what? It looks delicious.
You know, it's supposed to look like
you've got something to emulate at least.
Right.
And so when we did the specs for the book,
I had one of the best publishers in
America say, if you do that book,
there's no way you sell
more than 5,000 oh no way.
And no one's going to publish it and
you can't use metric and you can't use a
gram scale and you can't have that font
and you can't have those pictures and
full bleed and it'll cost
way too much to print.
And so it took about a month and a half
before I got lucky and I called a print
broker who had actually printed,
you know,
brokered the print job of one of the
famous books and I was expecting that the
book retails for $60 it would cost like
15 to print 20 I didn't know anything
about it.
And when he told me it was like $2 and
23 cents per book to print per thirty
thousand thirty thousand copy run. I
went no way like that. And he went, well,
it's probably less now. Like you
thought I meant it was like too much.
And instantaneously I went,
oh shit.
Like everything makes sense.
And when I would call publishers and
tell them this, there we go. Oh yeah,
but look like we did 40
different prints, la, you know,
40 different books last year. Only
five of them did well. And I'm like,
that's your problem man.
Like I know what we're going to sell.
Well I don't really give a shit if you
lost 35% of the time and it needs to
spread your portfolio risk, I'm the
one you're spreading it on. Right.
And so, um, so we decided,
um, with the Alinea book, um,
we put together like 20 pages and Martin
made this beautiful stainless steel
bracketing system and we shipped it
out to eight different publishers.
We like two of which were art houses
that had never done a cookbook.
And they all came back and,
and same all the usual criticism
except for Aaron Wayner.
It tends to be press smart, smart,
smart guy, by the way. Yeah.
And he basically said, I'm going to make
you an unusual offer, no advance at all.
And we can negotiate,
essentially,
we'll just be the distributor and we'll
negotiate out like what that looks like.
And we'll help you with the printing
and we'll help you with the editing,
which were both really good at.
And within 10,
we had struck a deal whereby any of
the books that we bought or sold for
ourselves, for our restaurant, we paid
actual printing costs, not wholesale,
a actual printing costs.
Um,
anything that they sold and
distributed through their channels,
they would get about
27% of the sale price,
which means that we've got 73% of
that. Um, these are like state secrets,
right? Like, like nobody tells this stuff.
And so for years I was walking around
with this knowledge where if we sold
100000 bucks, say, um,
that would be the equivalent of selling
like 500,000 bucks on any other deal.
And we got to control the quality of it.
And we won both the James
Beard Award for best, um,
cooking from a professional point of view,
best cookbook of the year. And we won.
I say we,
Martin and Laura Kasner one,
the communication arts award where if
you're a designer that's like their annual
is like,
that's like getting the the Oscar right.
Similarly for people who
don't know what I mean,
the James Beard awards are
also very much like the Oscars.
Yeah. So, so we felt like
really vindicated on that. Um,
the book still sells. This is eight
years later, we still sell seven,
8,000 copies a year. Um, and
when we did the Aviary, um,
which is our bar, that's a non bar,
um, that we talked about earlier. Um,
you know,
we started getting all of the same offers
again and this time it was really easy
to go, like, just kinda like,
oh, like, oh, that's cute. Like,
you know, um, and so I
should add that we did,
I wrote a,
a book of grant,
I wrote his memoir together that
we didn't use a ghost writer.
We wrote it ourselves called life
on the line. And for that one,
we did a traditional book deal,
but after our agent
kind of got it halfway,
I got on our plane and flew out there
and then brokered the deal myself. Um,
and I got,
um,
a giant multiple of the highest bid
by doing essentially a reverse Dutch
auction, starting at a really high
price and working my way downward.
Can you explain to people just
briefly with them? Yeah, yeah.
So basically like here, I'll
do this, like let's say I,
so I think one of the great problems like
to solve one of the black boxes is the
agency problem. Let's say you want to
sell your house, you put it on the market,
and the agent's going to get, I don't
know, four to 5% of the sale price.
That's a lot for something. It's like
your most biggest investment in your life.
Um, but they kind of say like,
they control the information,
they control the mls,
all that. Um, will they, if
they're the seller's agent,
get the highest price for you? And the
answer is almost certainly not. Um,
because they, let's say a house
is gonna sell for $500,000,
they're going to get 4% of that.
That's $20,000. If they get, um,
$490,000, um, it's almost no
difference to them write 400
bucks difference. But if they lose the
deal over that last 10,000, it's a lot.
So they want to price a home,
um,
so that it sells quickly so that they
can keep their deal flow going and they
don't really care about maximizing
their last dollar. Whereas for you,
that last dollar is actually like
$9,600. It's a lot more money. Um,
so what I do whenever I've sold real
estate is that I figured out what the
intrinsic value is of the house.
Like what's the bare minimum that
I'd be willing to sell it for?
And I price it just
slightly higher than that.
And I tell all the agents
and the whole town,
I will pay you 50% of everything
over 10% higher than that.
And they all say, oh, that's
against the real state ethics code.
Or I would never do that deal because
it was a vert all my other deals or
whatever.
And then what happens is two days later
you get like a dozen phone calls and
they've priced it like 40% higher
and they're like the, it
sells in two days. Yeah.
Cause now they're actually
working for you. Right. Well,
it similarly I went into that,
that publishing negotiation and I was
kind of like, by the way, the agent,
um, it's probably look up until
she's great like great person.
I don't think she even knows
that that's what was happening.
Do you know what I mean? Like, I don't
even think she knows it. Like, Hey,
she was brought up in this,
in this industry for this company
and that's the way it works.
And shoot for sure. Dispute
everything I just said. She would say,
I always try to get the highest price,
but I went in and I just went like,
look, I'm not gonna spend my time doing
this for x. So I need four times that.
And she was like,
there's no way you'll ever get that.
You've never written a book before. And
I said, well, we did the Alinea book.
That's a cookbook, doesn't count.
These are words, you know, so,
so I,
I went to the publishers that I'll bid
on it and I just got them all on a,
on a conference call and just started at
a really high price and every couple of
seconds I went down $10,000 and then
one of them blinked and bought it.
What was the great way? That's a
great method of price discovery. Um,
like if you think about it,
most auctions even like you
go to a charity event or
whatever and they start low
and they try to get interest going high.
It's often the case that if they start
really, really high and start going down,
people start going like, oh my God,
someone's gonna say something like,
I would pay that someone
else must as well.
They could be off by a factor of 30%
and they'll never even know it because
there's only one bid that ever happened.
So no one knows how off they are. No.
On that phone call where he's like,
hey guys,
would love to get you on the
phone and then publish right away.
So I guess my question is,
did they know that they were signing
up for a Mexican standoff slash Jesse?
Oh, they did. They did. I went and met
with them all personally. Kind of said,
if you're like, John, I'd love to get you
on the phone. And that's like, all right,
congratulations guys. Yeah, you can't,
you can't ambush people to
a Mexican standoff. Yes, you
can't do that. Um, I, I mean,
you could, it might be fun, but I didn't
do that. All right. I went and talked.
I created enticement. I sold on
my ability to actually do it. Um,
it was a bit like, um, doing the
no phones, um, with the software.
Like I was like,
well,
if I get a really big contract off to
figure out how to write and book and
there'll be a lot of pressure. Um,
and so, so I did that and, um, and,
and, and I wrote it and I turned it in on
time, which apparently no one does. Very,
very rare. But yeah, to them, like under
David's do, they went, what's this?
And I'm like, that's the manuscript.
Yeah. Oh that's cute. Well,
it's kind of like showing
up at the restaurant on time
as a diner and then being
seated at the appointment time.
It's just this like open,
open lie teaching your books
in time. I do actually. Yeah,
I believe that. Yeah. I do turn
my books in on time. Uh, and we,
we could get into that separate topic.
I just want to ask you a question. I do.
I do. I do not turn them in at the, uh,
expected length
longer perhaps.
I do tend to turn on.
So what happened with that,
but the aviary is that we,
like,
we basically couldn't figure
out how to do another book, um,
because the Alinea book was such a project
and Martin was on to other things and
we didn't want to do it traditionally.
And I didn't know anyone who
could do what we wanted to do.
And then there was this guy,
Ellen hamburger and boy,
if you get nothing else from this whole
talk and you've made it this far, um,
go see, go Google, uh,
Allen and Alinea. Um,
Allen is a procedural effects artists.
Uh,
he worked at what a studios and all the
hobbit movies doing like hair and water
and things like that. Um, so he writes
the physics that then makes the,
makes the magic. Right. Um, and then, uh,
he worked at Pixar and while he was
at Pixar and his wife Sarah worked at
industrial light and magic
as a graphics designer. Um,
he was given by Sarah a copy of the
Alinea book to go full circle and became,
just fascinated with it.
Was Not a cook,
didn't know how to cook and
did the Julie and Julia thing,
he spent five years not only,
um,
cooking his way through the entire book,
but also would do things like,
well,
I don't know where to get this plate.
And I've always wanted to
learn how to fire porcelain.
Alan for people wondering is a l l e n
there are also videos of Allen and Alinea.
Yeah.
And he's an autodidact.
Like this guy learns and learns and
learns and is the kind of person that goes
to the black box and goes,
I'm going to learn how to forge knives
and I'm going to learn how to fire
porcelain.
And by the way,
I'm going to cook everything in there
and I'm gonna take pictures of him and
make a book documenting that.
And when he asked if he could use
like we had kind of a little email
relationship and he came out to linea
wants to ask grant some questions about
how to make something cause it wasn't
working and when grant kind of threw up
his arms to go by,
the book might be wrong.
Like Ellen's world view was shattered. It
was like fine. And he was kind of like,
what you mean? It could be wrong. He goes,
well yeah we did have
some Murata in there.
Like I mean we documented hundreds
of recipes. It could be wrong.
And at that point like his mentality
change. It's in the video and,
and we got to know him and I got to
know him and when he sent me the book,
it wasn't what I was expecting.
I was expecting like a homegrown book.
And what I got was, you
know, a 400 page beautifully,
beautifully illustrated,
beautifully written book about
a person's journey of learning,
um, and it was called the
Alinea project. And I had no,
no idea that he had
done anything like this.
And so suddenly, um, I
thought to myself immediately,
and it's in the intro to the aviary book,
um,
I texted him and said,
Holy Shit, you're crazy.
And I have ideas.
And after waiting for like four or
five years to do a book on the Aviary,
I immediately was like,
this is the guy to do the book.
Now I need to lure him out of Pixar,
which is about the best
place to work in the world.
And then I found out his wife worked at
industrial light and magic and she did
all the graphic design and I was like,
this is perfect.
You guys need to quit your
jobs and moved to Chicago.
And they flew out, we had
some conversations about
what that might look like.
Um, it was very much a partnership.
Um, they would have equity in the book.
We would have creative freedom to
do it exactly the way we wanted. Um,
we knew more about the printing
and the bidding and all of that.
So I wasn't worried about
the economics of it anymore.
I was worried about trying to make
something really awesome and right as they
were about to say yes,
they were,
they found out that they
were going to have a baby.
So they called me up one day and said,
oh my God, like, and I was like, oh,
they got cold feet. Oh No. And he
said, you know, we're pregnant,
we're going to have a
baby. And I said, okay,
well we're going to wait a year because
there's no way in the world I'm letting
you move out out of your comfort zone
and have a child and to have that change
of life.
And they thought I was like punting
on them just because like in a
discriminatory way. And I
said, nope, we're not going
to do this with anyone else.
We will wait as long as it takes.
And about a year and a half later,
they moved to Chicago and we spent
the last year and a half, um,
set up a studio of our own, spent the
last year and a half doing this book. Um,
did a Kickstarter to just
essentially raise awareness for it.
We raised almost half a million
dollars in the Kickstarter.
We sold about another $300,000 a book
since then. Uh, it comes out in October.
Um,
you can go the Alinea book.com.
And the coolest part of that website
is that if you look at the Alinea book,
I'll, sorry, DVD book.com,
very ugly, very late.
It's marketing right there. So, um,
yeah, the Aviary book.com. But if you,
the coolest part of that is other than
of course your ability to buy said book
is um, Alan kept a blog on
there called our progress.
And in it he details every single aspect
of what it takes to make a book like
this right down to line screens.
And compositing photos of,
you know,
like one of the things that every single
book publisher told me is that you
can't sell a cocktail
book from earning $30.
There's no market for it and you don't
need pictures because it's just a liquid
in a glass.
And I think we blew that out of the
water with what the book looks like. Um,
I think that because certain things
like fire are really hard to photograph.
Um, there's a great picture in
there of this one cocktail where we,
we spray some antidotes and we light it
on fire and it creates an aroma into the
bowl that it's served in. It's
called loaded to the gun walls. Um,
it's a Batavia rock cocktail.
And like that took a composite
of 18 different photographs.
And so he breaks down the photography
techniques and also the New York Times
bestseller list. And I showed
him like how, you know,
Google target marketing works and
Facebook ads work and all that.
And all of a sudden he went, Holy
Shit, I had no idea you could do this.
So we are going completely
without a distributor and
publisher of this time. Um,
and I think we're going to set a man,
I don't know,
like I,
I'm either completely delusional.
It wouldn't surprise me if we sold
a half a million of these. Yeah.
And in the next two or three
years and it's, yeah, it's not a,
not a nine 95 book either,
which it shouldn't be. Right.
I mean, this is, it's $85.
Um,
we've invested close to a million dollars
all the way in around it and it looks
like it. I think, I hope, um, yeah.
From what about, from what I've seen,
it looks like it would cost more than
that. Yeah. Well we did, you know,
we did it all ourselves too. Um, you know,
it's really like a five person project.
Um, it's, it's deep enough that
if, if a professional gets it,
they're gonna learn a lot.
Um, but I'd say about 35,
40% of it can be done at home because
unlike the Alinea book where Hey,
you've got to go out and
buy duck, like, you know,
in your local grocery might not
have this kind of duck or whatever.
If you need some Florida kind of
run or you know, um, you know,
a certain kind of Tequila or whatever,
you just go to your local liquor store
and it's exactly the same thing that we
use. Um, you know, that
product is universal.
I read somewhere that the, I don't
think it's taking us too far afield.
I read somewhere that you
consider yourself as Keela
guy or at least in part a
Tequila guy.
Do you have any favorite
tequilas or concoctions?
Well, there's, so I just am going
to do a little video promo for um,
for the book that we just filmed last
week where essentially I work with Eric
[inaudible] who's one of our
bartenders in the office,
which is our little
speakeasy below the aviary,
which is amazing if people have
the opportunity to check it out.
It's basically grant said,
hey, everything upstairs.
People are gonna think it's
Alinea smoke and mirrors.
We need to prove we can
make a real cocktail.
So one of the foundational
cocktails for me is, is a Daiquiri.
It's a, I say three ingredients
in a million ways to fuck
it up. You know, it's,
it's just lime, sugar and rum.
That's all it is. And, uh,
and yet like most bars you go into will
make a terrible Daiquiri or they'll
blend it or blah, blah, blah. Right?
But a great Daiquiri is really,
really transformative. So
did a video on that. Um,
and then I always make a half mescal
Margarita. That's my favorite drink.
All I'm doing is I'm taking some reposado
and a little bit of mezcal and equal
weights along with, um,
some, uh, you know, uh,
grandma or nay or quantro equivalent
and lime and simple syrup.
That's it. That's all there is to it. Um,
man, I love the simple stuff like that.
And then we have a whole section in the
book on old whiskeys, dusty bottles, um,
old gins.
Like there's a growing movement to kind
of rediscover some of the distilleries
in America that were really,
really, really great, um,
that don't exist anymore.
Um, that were more artisinal at the time.
And you can still find those bottles, um,
around, uh, it's a little bit
easier than like, you know,
someone like wine collecting or
something like that. And um, I mean it's,
it's like an endlessly fascinating thing.
I don't consider myself a
cocktail person 10 years ago.
I really loved wine.
Um,
I felt like from a health
perspective it was better as well.
But just like anything else,
if you have a well constructed
cocktail and something of high quality,
um,
it's an additive thing.
Like you can have it in a meal and it
can make the meal better. Um, you know,
whereas it's like, you know, a
vodka tonics just boozing, um,
has just getting drunk. Um, that's
not what we're trying to do here.
We're trying to make things that are,
it's really a culinary approach
to cocktails and a man. It's,
it's endlessly fascinating. Just like
anything else in this world. And the,
the, the, I would also
say just contrasting,
say someone who wants to
recreate something from Alinea,
which you certainly could do.
I mean Ellen prove that with
something from the aviary. The,
there's also a tremendous amount of
theater and presentation dynamism that you
can create with cocktails that does
not have to be super expensive or super
complicated. Uh, that, uh,
I mean certainly you guys are able
to go as complex as you want to go,
which is stunning and I've spent
time at the Aviary, but it's all,
you can easily make some ice with patriots
bitters in it or something like that.
And then as the ice
melts and the cocktail,
it's going to change the flavor and
it's going to look really cool too.
I'm doing some of these things
at home is, is not hard. Um,
I did a dinner party once
where it was like, you know,
a cocktail party probably had 40 people
at my house and each room in my house
had all of the ingredients for the
cocktail and then a little instructions
on how to make it themselves.
So that took away the need for a
bartender because they're terrible anyway.
Anyone that you'd bring in
and you know that, you know,
a caterer or something like that.
And the other cool thing is that people
got really into it. They went like, oh,
like I only know how to make
an old fashion. Now I know
how to make a Manhattan.
Um, you know, uh,
the one that I discovered that party
was a Frisco's sour had like Benedictine
whiskey and lemon, you know,
it was really delicious.
So it can be,
it can be more than just
like a strong cocktail.
It can be really delicate and interesting
and people can learn all
about this@theaviarybook.com.
Is that right? Right. Yup. Well, nick,
I've have to rapid fire
questions that are unrelated.
And then I think we're gonna,
we're gonna,
we're gonna bring this neat
and tidy round one podcast, uh,
to, uh, to, uh, to a close.
But we've talked about books and everybody
should not only check out the aviary
book, but also if they have a
chance to go to the aviary. It is,
it is tremendous.
And you can also get some
delicious bites and food.
Uh, at least last time I was there stuck
in at the aviary. So it is a bit of a,
I hesitate to call it a work around,
but you guys have some very,
very popular establishments.
If you want to sample the food,
this is also a great way to do it. Uh, and
the drinks are just incredible. So it's,
it's a real sort of destination that
makes a trip to Chicago a worth it and of
itself. So I would recommend
not only checking out the book,
but also checking out a lot
of what you guys are up to.
Aside from that books you've gifted the
most other people outside of those that
you've made yourself,
what are the books that you've
gifted the most to other people?
Yeah, I named one of them already.
Um, the fooled by randomness,
almost everyone in my office is
forced to read that. Um, you know, um,
and I've, I've definitely
given that away. Um, boy,
that's a tricky one because I just,
like I said, I can't remember.
I can't remember books. Um, very well,
but that's certainly probably number
one. Um, on a business side of things.
And then the, on the other side, um,
I tend to give away what I
would call vintage art books.
So it's not a book people can buy,
I'm sorry to say,
but occasionally I'll be like,
you used bookstore and I'll find some
of these great old art books and I buy a
few of them. And then when I, when I
want to thank someone for something,
I send him that
peregrinations of an epicurean,
something like that. Yeah.
I mean at the end of the day,
like
I bought like when I want
to give someone something,
I tried to make it something that you and
I really want to make it a great gift.
Um, I try to get it something
that you can't buy. Right.
And so I bought an old
typewriter and I write,
when I write a thank you note,
I type it up on the old typewriter and it
is the most confounding thing to people
because they look at it and they go,
how did you do that?
I'm like on a 1922 type writer.
Um,
it's like a personal
artisinal thing. Um, but I,
I know that that's not what
you're getting at. No, I can't,
I can't really think of, I can't
really think of like the number one.
I'm sure once we, we, we end this, I'll
immediately think of it. And if I do,
I'll send it to you so you can link to it.
I think the answer, the answer is more
interesting with the typewriter. So I,
I think, uh, what I'm getting
at was whatever you just
offered, so that's perfect.
And if you come up with anything else, we
can put it in the show notes. Uh, this,
this next one. It can be tough at times
for folks, but the billboard questions,
so metaphorically speaking,
noncommercial, no advertising,
but if you could get a, a
word, a quote, a sentence,
a question up on a billboard to transmit
something to millions or billions of
people. Does anything come to mind
that you might put on that billboard?
I don't know why this came to mind,
but the, but the word would be pause.
Hmm.
As it, I have no idea why that
came to mind, but I think in,
in talking through this
whole thing, you know, it's,
you, you kept asking me like, why are
you digging this black box or whatever,
or it'd be like, um, curiosity,
like, and I think those are two,
I'm thinking of those in the same
way. I'm not saying pause, like stop.
I'm saying think right.
And so I think, um,
you know, the, the hallmark of,
of the people that I like as friends the
best is what we try to instill in our
kids. Uh, you know, and,
and the reason I like my wife so much
and all that is that intellectual
curiosity is everything.
And so, um, I dunno,
how do you get that on a billboard?
I think pause or, you know,
be curious or something like
that. I know it's Cliche, but I,
I think that's the thing,
the thread that ties everything together.
Yeah.
You do pause a lot.
Even though on a macro
level you seem to be moving,
uh,
at hyper speed a lot of the time.
There are a lot of pauses built into
that. Speed, if that makes sense.
From what I've noticed.
I mean your assignment,
you are simultaneously one of the
craziest fuckers I know and uh,
least craziest fuckers.
I know. If that makes,
that's a great counselor. I'll
take, I'll take it. I'll take it.
And uh,
where can people find you?
I know you have of course the Alinea
group.com you have Splore talk.com,
the Aviary,
book.com,
which is the sort of the most timely
for people to check out right now.
If people want to say hello or
follow you on social where the best,
uh, best, best places, best handles
for that. Yup. Uh, Instagram, uh,
which is ending conus,
Kyoko nes and uh,
Twitter is Nick Kokonas
and I C K and uh, hey,
it's all googleable, right?
Like so that if you could figure it out,
my email address and I'll probably answer,
although given the given the reach of,
of, of your podcast, perhaps I will be
inundated and might take a while. Yeah,
that might be a hug of death situation,
but we will say TBD problem to have
I suppose. Good problem to have.
Nick, this was a blast. Thank you so
much for taking the time. I really,
really appreciate him and many
more conversations to be had this.
I think another trip to Chicago may be
in order, so say I hope we see you here.
So I know I need to get back
and to everybody listening,
we've made mention of the show notes,
links to everything we've discussed,
which you will be able to
find at tim.blog/podcast as
with this episode and uh,
certainly every other episode.
And until next time,
thank you so much for listening.
Hey guys, this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before
you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the, uh, the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that, check it
out. Just go to four hour work week.com.
That's four hour workweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one. And
if you sign up, I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by
Charlotte's web, which makes a CBD oil,
a hemp extract that has become
one of my go to tools. Now,
I have never really talked about CBD oil
and cannabis has never really been the
plant for me. I know we're talking
about head, uh, but nonetheless,
after several nights of inexplicably
insomnia, this is about a year ago.
I just could not get to sleep to save
my life and after other fixes failed,
so Melatonin California poppy extract
of it ended up in a lead athlete,
introduced me to this non psychoactive
extract. Then Bam, problem solved.
I had some of the best sleep
that I've had in months.
Now I don't use sleep
aids on a daily basis,
but this has become part of my toolkit
and I hope to be exploring other
applications soon.
CVD oil products have exploded in
popularity in the health and wellness and
fitness worlds and Charlotte's web is one
of the top players that offers a broad
spectrum hemp extract with
CVD in the form of oils,
capsules and topical products.
Charlotte's web products will not get
you high so that maybe that is good news,
may have bad news to you,
but it does have some powerful benefits
and the applications and it works with
your body's existing
endocannabinoid system.
Endo meaning from within
like endo versus exoskeleton.
Francis endocannabinoid
system works with your body.
Some of the most common uses are for
leaf from everybody's stressors help in
supporting restful sleep, which
is what I most often use for, uh,
to bring about a sense of calm and focus.
A lot of my friends who's for that CBD
is also known on becoming known for
helping athletes to recover from
exercise induced inflammation.
Charlotte's web hemp extract has
naturally occurring terpenes, flavonoids,
and other valuable have compounds
that works synergistically to heighten
positive effects, sometimes
referred to as the entourage effect,
but you guys can look up making it
more complete than a single compound.
CBE alternatives,
at least that is what I've been told by
not a bunch about CBD alternative North
Single compound. In
any case, check it out.
This stuff has really worked for me to
jump over to CW hemp.com forward slash
Tim CW isn't Charlotte's web CW hemp.com
forward slash Tim to take a quick quiz
which will determine the best product
for your particular aims, lifestyle,
etc. And they shipped to all 50 states.
Charlotte's web are offering listeners
of this podcast 10% off of their
purchase.
While there are some exclusions.
I personally use the extra strength CBD
oils for the extra strength and capsules
and a,
you can see what might be a fit for you
on that page and there is a 30 day risk
free guaranteed,
so why not try not to get 10% off of your
purchase@cwhemp.com forward slash Tim
and disclaimer,
these statements have not been evaluated
by the food and Drug Administration.
This product is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any disease.
Enjoy. This episode is
brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is the global
creative platform,
makes it easy for designers and clients
to work together from logos to Apps,
business cards, packaging
to books. You name it.
99 designs is the Goto design
resource for any budget. Right now.
My listeners,
that's you guys can get $50 off a logo
and brand identity package from 99
designs plus a free upgrade that let you
promote your project on the platform,
which is an additional $99 value by
checking out 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim 50 that's Tim five zero so nine
nine designs.com forward slash Tim 50 as
many of you know, I've used 99
designs for many, many years now.
I've used them for book covers,
putting mock ups for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number
one New York Times bestseller,
illustrations for the multivolume of the
Tao of Seneca ebook series basically,
and other graphic design projects and
I've been very impressed by the quality of
their designers and illustrators and you
can check out all sorts of stuff like
Tao of Seneca to get an idea. Uh,
they're, they're really mind boggling.
Most recently I used 99 designs to uptick
illustrations and layout of my five
morning rituals ebook.
This is a pdf that I offer as an
incentive to get people to sign up for my
newsletter.
The illustrations inside are gorgeous
and I loved working with the designer.
We ended up selecting for the project.
You can take a look at that.
This is a real world example
of the type of thing.
Then I use 99 designs
for@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim 50 99 designs
designers search tool connects you
directly with one designer based on design
category or industry specialization
style, skill level availability, and more.
You just check off the boxes that you
need to satisfy the criteria you want and
it will bring up the best matches.
Or You could start a contest.
You invite the entire community
to take a shot at your project.
Then you pick your favorite,
so to get $50 off your first logo
and brand identity package as well as
additional promotion on the platform.
With the free upgrade,
please visit 99 designs.com forward slash
Tim 50 that's 99 designs.com forward
slash 10 50 and click on the
link on the landing page,
check it out and I nine designs.com
forward slash 10 the 50.